i went there
to egypt and it confirmed what i was
already highly suspicious of which is
that something spectacular was happening
on earth that humans were doing amazing
things and it confirmed it whether it's
the assyrian for sure um the serpent
with the center time boxes the great
pyramid and everything else i'm like
okay but in the great pyramid in the
king's chamber the frequency was really
high i just think they were energy
centers i think that perhaps they were
used for healing um perhaps they were
used to somehow sort of charge up in
some kind of ways even to rebalance and
maybe there was i don't know
communication with other
extraterrestrials maybe that's where it
happened because of the alignment with
orion's belt and the pyramids and and
the way that they use the stars perhaps
as sort of like a almost like a like a
direction it's like directions it's like
yeah it's like oh yeah it could be land
here like we're here yeah ping ping like
land here come come and get us hey hey
alien overlords that dropped us off and
left us
welcome to the pretty intense podcast uh
today on the show is a very fascinating
guest his name is jimmy corsetti he has
a youtube channel called bright insight
and i've been following his videos for
years in fact the way that it came along
was there was something i posted on
instagram somebody that replied you
should check out and he had his handle
on instagram and so i just like curious
every now and again i clicked on it and
i was like oh man i've watched these
dudes videos his videos are about um
ancient civilizations and the mysteries
of the world that we have yet to find
out so whether they're about ancient
egypt or atlantis or the moon or jfk
or
mayan cultures i mean he's made videos
on all of them in many different ways
and he's traveled to a lot of them uh
himself so
we just talked all about it it was just
all i mean it was a really longest
episode on history so far i'm pretty
sure um and it was just all about
ancient civilizations a little bit about
his background and where he came from
and then we went into all of them we
stopped talked about the younger dryas
which is where there was supposedly well
there was a cataclysm that sent the
world into a cold phase and then when we
came out of it into anunnakis and
atlantis and egyptians and mayan
cultures and the sumerians
and then of course we touched on stuff
that has to do with it which is like
honestly magic and manifesting and the
power that we have within us and what i
think is very untapped
and i'm not just talking about the
people talking about myself um and so
it's just like hopefully a really
inspiring and fascinating conversation
um that will be very thought provoking
uh and my guess is maybe inspire you to
go to egypt afterwards but
anyway enjoy the episode if you like
this episode and you want to see more
please make sure that you hit the
subscribe button so that you get
notifications when a new one posts i
don't know i have a good feeling about
2022 i feel pretty good about it i do
too actually i was telling this uh
someone this the other day i'm like i
think that they're the future is bright
but i was going to mention as far as
like these little hiccups you know i
just noticed and some people think i'm
crazy but i i feel like there's
something to it we're about to hit
mercury retrograde in the next we're
less than two weeks out and they say
that once you're at that two week before
or after that's when like weird things
start happening
and i
i think there could be something to it i
think
are just our
part pardon the cosmos why wouldn't
there be things that would influence us
but anyways because a lot of people say
there's all hiccups and electronics and
other things and just like never make
plans contracts
yeah they said don't do that and um
so here we are because it starts like um
i got what day but like we're already
they say the effects started on december
28th
and so we're already into it
even though it hasn't gone right full
retrograde yet it will do that in like i
don't know ten like less than two weeks
i um i took two levels of astrology i
definitely believe in a lot of it which
is why i did it i would say that
if you allow it to be your guide it can
be
meaning like if you go here comes
retrograde and you're like here comes
the you know the taurus moon so anyway i
do believe in some of that stuff but i
don't follow it nearly as much now but
you know it's more like it's almost like
a
astrology almost ends up becoming almost
like a like a psychic reading of some
sort where
you get it and it kind of doesn't really
make sense until you're in it or past it
and then you're like oh
because like if you know the
retrograde's coming it's like you know
could you anticipatorily like add in
your own sort of color to that situation
and look for things and then find them
possibly but it's like if we're in it
and i'm like i don't know cancellations
all these things technical whatever and
then you go if we're in retrograde then
it's almost like it's almost a little
bit of confirmation um but i don't i
don't let it guide me so we're not gonna
go down too far down the uh astrology
rabbit hole right i was gonna say i
think part of it is because i guess i've
been playing with the universe and just
studying it i think that we're creators
in more ways than we realize like our
thoughts intentions words all bring
things to fruition
and i think that just the very belief in
itself whether it's placebo whatever
like i think that could create things
because it's like even the placebo
effect is a real thing they do
scientific studies for medicine all the
time and there always has to be a
placebo it's only way to do a proper
study and yet there's still these
miraculous cases of people that are
cured from various ailments because they
thought they got something and they
believed it and i think there's
something to it so whether it's like 100
crystals yeah whether it's crystals or
horoscopes or other things i think that
your level anyone's level of belief
is the defining difference i really
think that i think if you believe that
these things make an impact well then it
is true for you
thoughts become things
i they do i do believe this firmly
firmly believe that i mean i can look at
that even with my own career and things
like that that it was because i just
truly believed it was going to happen
and it was going to work out that i
think it did because there's really no
good reason why it should have
like a little girl from roscoe illinois
my dad wasn't a famous race car driver
like we didn't have a ton of money you
know there's all kinds of reasons why i
wouldn't but i just really
freaking believed it was going to happen
anything that you see was originally a
thought form
it was somebody with a an idea and then
it got created and so
there's a there's a there's a chain of
events that happens after you think of
it but it's first formed with thought
and of course as we
well know and i have interviewed people
about this nothing is firm and solid
even us like we think it is it's just
vibrating at a slower frequency to
create this matter when i interviewed
neil degrasse tyson a while back you
know i confirmed with him about you know
whether or not there's how much matter
there really was and if you put all the
people together and i was like i heard
it's like the size of an apple and he's
like yeah that's about right and i'm
like oh my god the guy that discovered
that actually was afraid to put his feet
on the floor in the morning because he
was afraid he would just fall through
because he realized that like nothing is
actually solid it that's actual total
science though to say it's like
vibration and
because it's like
if atoms exist which i don't doubt and
no one like the whole scientific
community like seems to agree like this
atoms are a thing like they and they're
bound together through this mysterious
electrical force none of them are
touching each other and they're actually
separated by vast distances compared to
like their actual size so that means
that all of this is by definition an
illusion because it's not what we think
like it's not what the human eyes are
picking up on
and and
my whole life has changed with the very
concept or the shift i guess
in my thoughts of awareness itself of
what like our human experience is in the
universe and that i think all of this is
a big
illusion but in a good way illusion not
in a negative way um not like uh
but like
if that's the case that things are all
held together through this force
and here we are talking about it and we
also experience sensations like love and
emotion and whether it's humor and
anything else joy
uh or even sorrow i think that right
there is the
to me it's the evidence that there is
far more to this because some people
have like a nihilistic view on things
they think wow it's like a primordial
soup type thing all of the whole
universe is just an accident it's
enough chemicals mixed together with
heat and water and ta-da here we are i'm
like
no i don't i think the fact that i'm
questioning meaning the fact that i
wonder to myself well why does love or
other why do these things exist why do i
exist why do humans like what's this
about and the fact that i can sit here
and talk to you about it through a phone
you know through wireless all this crap
like you know even
uh whether it's changing the tv station
or the radio station it's all a
frequency right and you see something
totally different when you press this
one little button no one gives it any
thought
but yet instantaneously we could see
something on the other side of the world
like that
i don't know i think all of this is the
evidence right in front of us that we're
that there's far more going on behind
the the scenes or or the veil of the
human eyes i like to say um i think the
proof is right here
i've had so many are you familiar with
synchronicities oh i yeah
i hope for them all the time
and i i believe it's like as carl jung
said because he was like big into this
and he was like the father of analytical
psychology and he's he was a he
researched synchronicies he didn't know
what to make of him because he had some
miraculous ones and he was a believer by
the way i'm like
freud or nietzsche's like that's one
thing i like about young he's a believer
in something and he used to study this
and he believed that just the conscious
putting it out there that they do exist
that they would happen more frequently
and it's happened to me and do you want
to hear a story it's course that's the
best part like i want all the stories
you have please so i have some i have
some miraculous ones but i'll keep those
to myself or for another time but there
was one you're going to withhold the
miraculous ones
well this one all right let me share one
and okay so this is like a year ago i
was living in boise idaho
and i was literally one evening having
like these thoughts like about
synchronicities and my relationship to
the universe and everything
and it was at night it was time for bed
i was already like done doing my little
go to bed routine i let the dogs out and
um
all of a sudden i had this random
impulse thought i don't know where it
came from but it's like just go outside
to the backyard and i had a lovely
backyard it was nice and dark out there
i was like the boise foothills and like
you see the stars
and um all of a sudden like i'm just
wandering around i'm just and i walk to
the corner of my yard and all of a
sudden like i'm just looking up at the
stars and all of a sudden i had this
impulse thought
and it all happened to say like in less
than a second because you know thoughts
are they happen so quick but it was like
contemplating my existence in the
universe and synchronicities and like a
belief that i'm tied to consciousness or
whatever and
i remember thinking to myself if i
see a shooting star right now it's
confirmation
and at that exact moment i look up and
to my left like keep on i didn't think
about this it wasn't like let me look
for a shooting star this happened like
instantaneously so for me anyone
listening to this story is going to
dismiss him like coincidence whatever
but i know what happened and that's why
it's difficult to share these things
because some people blow it off and i'm
like i was there i remember and it was
not controllable i i just looked to the
left and then at that exact moment
a shooting star went right over my head
in this direction and let me just say it
wasn't like
okay
um
you know a shooting star caught my
peripheral vision over here and then i
thought of it like subconsciously no it
was i looked
and then it happened but between the
thought of like if i see it now and me
looking was
like we're talking
not like a second which is really quick
and to me it was like
my jaw dropped i knew what happened i
got goosebumps i was like
something had happened i felt like i
would i describe it as i witnessed a
miracle because i couldn't replicate
that i didn't plan for it it wasn't like
i'm looking up all day looking for a
shooting star and once i see it it's
confirmation this was i don't know
where i'm going with this is i don't
know where the impulse came
to think of that thought and look
because i wasn't thinking about it at
that moment
and where did it come from that's my
question and to me it was like it was
just confirmation that oh my god there's
like there's something else happening
and i want to know who what was it was
it myself what made me the i the i am
that say consciousness
what made me look in that direction at
that moment it was a big wine [ __ ]
was that no it's a mind expander i i
would say
was that the impetus
no that wasn't you've been on you said
this was only a year ago this is just a
synchronicity so then what was the
impetus that sent you on this path to
make because you've been making videos
on youtube now for five years
yeah probably since
2016-ish maybe yeah and they're all
about atlantis and the moon and
all kinds of absolutely fascinating
ancient stories especially with egypt so
um which is of course where i got really
hooked um and so what what was it that
that turned it for you because you also
used to
be in the service like you served in the
army
yeah i saw his army national guard and i
volunteered because i uh i was inspired
by 911 and um do you want to hear this
quick because i never everyone's
everyone my following didn't know hardly
anything about me until i was on another
podcast recently i never shared my name
i didn't people didn't know who the hell
i was or what i had done because i was
just so private i'm like afraid of the
internet i'm like i don't know i'm just
gonna be private jimmy
so this will tie into like what i call
an awakening because part of like me
going into the service and volunteering
to go to
i always say iraq it's pronounced iraq i
mean no disrespect but my body's always
iraq um but it's a rock and um
this like because of that it led into my
awakening because like it was a reality
check after the years after i came home
realized like oh my god like what i
thought about a reality was much
different i had i felt i had been
deceived so here's the story so i was
always mister patriot and like i always
maybe i saw too many movies as a kid or
like both my grandfathers were world war
ii vets my father was a vietnam vet
and then i was a senior in high school
in 911 and i was
just profoundly affected i was
devastated by it because like that was a
very
um impressionable age to witness that on
tv you know senior in high school
because you're thinking you're you're
growing and you're you're you think you
know everything and
anyway so
i was really really bothered by that and
um i ended up having a few knee
surgeries uh one in high school and the
years after but that whole time i was
like really really putting a lot of
thought into like i'm gonna enlist i'm
gonna go volunteer um and what happened
was
i was working on atm machines and i had
this partner we're going around the
valley just working on atm machines for
chase and other banks and um
so this guy his name was i don't know
where he's at now but ali al-tahimi he
was an iraqi refugee so back in the late
90s
um
he there was a civil war in iraq down in
albazra the second largest town and they
tried to overthrow saddam because he was
a tyrannical
he was a bad dude
and
long story short they lost because he
sent his whole military into tanks and
and the stories he was telling me and
keep on he was like in elementary school
when this was happening
um and the stories he was telling me as
it would be like in this vehicle all day
driving around from atm to atm machine
and this is keep in mind this is like
we're talking 2005. so this is like
the only thing you saw on tv was the
iraq war right
and i don't know if people remember what
it was like back then that was the only
thing that was on the news and um
so
he was telling me stories like he saw
people be killed as a kid and he knew it
had impacted him and uh he was telling
me the story he was like in the street
playing around and there was like a gun
fight and this older guy was like hey
get out of here get out of here it's not
safe and then poof
he got shot in the head in front of him
and he's like
devastating to see us like he was like
fourth grade
and then so this is like during the
civil war and then what saddam did he
sent the his republican guard door to
door and albazra
and the what they did was they took the
eldest son from every household and they
were never seen or heard from again
and his brother his oldest brother was
17 at the time but he wasn't a
non-combatant he said my brother was
home he wasn't engaged in anything he
didn't do anything
and he was taken and the family never
heard from him again so they he he hated
saddam he was so happy we invaded he
said i'm gonna enlist i'm going there
too and uh he's like because he's like
saddam killed my brother he said a
million saddam killed my brother and um
so he ended up enlisting as an iraqi
refugee and i was like oh let me let me
just say so after that happened his
parents sent him and his siblings out of
the country uh they had to go through a
few different countries and they linked
up with some distant relatives here in
arizona and he had been here ever since
so i was like blown away because this
was all at a time and i'm like maybe i
should enlist and go do my part i'm
gonna go liberate the iraqi people i
feel like we're witnessing the nazis
like do terrible things we need to stop
them
so i was so like that's what i enlisted
i enlisted in in june of 2006
and i'm like i'm gonna volunteer to go
to iraq and i did and so i was i ended
up going in 2009 and 10
and um everything about it was different
than what i imagined like from what i
saw on tv i was like what are we doing
here i was like
i went there thinking i was going to
liberate these people because i saw on
tv they were waving us in and it's like
only the bad guys that are hurting
hurting us
and i'll never forget it my first
mission out
we so i was military police and not not
like law enforcement police i was combat
mp so we do convoy security we would
like you know escort people around so
one of the things we would do is train
the iraqi police and we go to the iraqi
police stations and they hated us most
of them were prior army and they were
like the same guys killing us and
shooting us when we moved in or invaded
i should say
and so every time we talk to these
people we have to go through an
interpreter and the interpreters would
say
they start and end every single sentence
with tell the invader this so be having
a conversation like tell the invader why
are you here and i remember being
devastated thinking like i just i just
want to help you like what sure anyway
so i'm getting yeah so i'm getting
long-winded here but it was like it was
an eye-opener because i'm like you know
you saw as we were there as invaders in
a different country that we were
completely ruining these people's day by
shutting down roads or telling them to
go a different direction you can't go
here and
as in so in someone else's country and
let me just say i wasn't anti-war at
that point it took me a couple years
after i got home that i was seeing
different news reports and thinking like
the media's lying like what this isn't
accurate like what's happening i started
to realize like this wasn't what i
thought it was this was big business
like i saw the infrastructure we were
setting up on our bases while we were
there and knowing what i know now and i
know i'm all over the place um but i end
up going back to school and get a
master's of business and
then it all started to make sense i'm
like this is big business like this was
this was about real money because we
went there and we set up shop with no
intention to leave
like that was planned from the get-go
and i didn't understand it at the time
i'm like this was more than some search
for wmd this was like this was a
strategic money-making grab on the likes
of which most people don't even want to
believe oh yeah of course how how what
was the indicator that this was set up
to stay
how did you know that
the infrastructure whether it's like we
call the chow house of the dining
facilities the gyms the the housing
facilities everything on base and
there's you know 100 bases throughout
the country
like they were the infrastructure they
were more than just tents they were
building like they were while we were
there so this is all right so i'm gonna
this is all right so this is like
dangerous ground but i'm just going to
say it because many people are not
um so there's a company called kbr
stands for kellogg brown and roots and
they are the
um they do all the logistics for the
united states military whether it's food
transportation
moving in and out like you know we're
talking hundreds of millions of tons of
equipment that's the company and i've
never seen like let me just say and this
is like this was like a good thing but
they fed us really good so if we had
every sunday with steak and lobster tail
and they had crab legs seven days a week
it was wonderful um and so i remember
thinking like look at all this money so
long story short i end up like digging
into them years later after i got home
and do you know who so this is this work
gets wild do you know who is the vice
president of kbr
up until
up until the invasion or i should say
let me back up until the presidential
election george bush all right i'll just
tell you senior
george or no dick cheney
dick cheney
and everyone was saying he was like the
mastermind so like so he was the vice
president for kbr and then he resigned
when he got on the ticket as the vice
presidential candidate for george w
and then i started and i remember
reading all about this and if you go
look at it now it's like they try to
bury this because kbr
in new york let me just say the new york
times reported on this like in 2007 or
eight or whatever year it was maybe it
was 2011. i don't remember but there was
like more than um what was it i forgot
like a hundred billion with a b i could
be wrong on that something like that of
over charges by this company
um
and like there was all this audits and
the like the the they fired the guy that
was asking all the questions so one of
the guys who worked for the pentagon was
like oh there's like a real issue here
they fired him and replaced him with a
guy that turned out that shut down the
whole investigation you can read this
this is not wow at least they didn't
kill him i mean that's not even that's
not a reason in the in the landscape of
the world as we know it now
yeah so tonight i don't want to go too
deep but like it's like like i started
adding these things together and
realizing that money drives the world
and there are bad people out there that
would do anything for a dollar but i had
a police officer friend tell me once
they investigated a murder over one
dollar summit somebody got in a fight
over a dollar and killed the other guy a
dollar one one dollar
and i'm like it just goes to show you
that if you're talking hundreds of
billion or billions to say people coming
you know that want to be billionaires
you know the truth is stranger than
fiction there are people that would
literally sacrifice lives
and um so anyways long story short that
kind of sent me down a path of realizing
like man like i never would have
believed
that my own
because i had friends that died and like
i never would have believed that like
something like this would actually
happen so it was kind of an awakening
that sent me down the path of like hey
you know sometimes you think you know
something
for certainty
and you and you learn and you end up
finding that you're wrong and it's very
humbling but it's also very liberating
to realize like hey you don't know
everything you just don't
so obviously you're miffed by
uh the integrity of the country and
you're also probably on a fundamental
level
your
your questioning for how things work has
been rocked because now you're like wow
this one thing that i believed in so
much that's really foundational with our
country and something that's happened
for
hundreds of years like hmm now what and
so
where what was it then that got you into
the realm of ancient mysteries and
understanding
uh what it's really all about and what's
going on uh what what drove your
fascination with egypt and all those
kinds of places so let's go back to 2014
i was working in a corporate type job
where i was investigating fraud for a
company and i started to really dread
going i went from getting hired on and
like excited to go to work and then over
a few years i was like dreading it like
waking up to the alarm and like really
not wanting to go to work because i
didn't like i don't like a set schedule
jimmy jimmy operates better on his own
time and
and if you ask me to do things that i
don't i'm not excited about it's like
it's tough and i was looking for other
positions nothing was panning out and i
ended up having a knee surgery and i
think this was the precipice because i'm
a very active person i'm fidgety i like
to move around and i think this knee
surgery
like facilitated a depression that i had
never experienced i didn't know what
depression was until i experienced it
and between being couch ridden for
months on end and crutches were like
rough for me
and hating my job and um i was married
and that wasn't going well and i was
my best friend was killed in afghanistan
and that devastated me
and i was already questioning like what
the hell is going on in this world
and um so there's a lot of things all at
once and there i was on the couch
i'd already i had already been
fascinated by the ancients as a kid i
thought it was a fun topic and i just
started digging into it i don't know
what video was i came across
but one that i do remember is that this
gentleman brian forrester who does like
tours of ancient sites i've i've met him
a few times i went to peru and he did
with them lovely man he lives in peru
and i came across this video of him in
egypt at the pla this place called the
serpent which has a few dozen
100 ton stone boxes that are carved out
of one piece of of stone and these
stones were moved some 500 miles away
and are a complete mystery it's like one
of the most bizarre things i've ever
seen in my life
and i was a video i'm like i've never
seen this before i don't understand how
i've never heard of this before
and so i started and he's talking about
mohs scale the the hardness of these
stones and that the egyptians that we
know of were not did not have the
tooling capable of cutting these things
to this precision and so i started i'm
like okay let me just google let me just
do my own little research here and kind
of like dig into this to see if like
this is if there's truth to this
and i started looking into it i listened
to what like the naysayers say i look at
what the
everyone scientists all over the place
and i just think for myself i'm like
holy crap like this is actually a
mystery like there's no explanation for
how they cut and carve these stones or
move them 500 miles up and down hill
yeah and i'm like what the hell so that
sent me down this path i'm like this is
fun i was already depressed and
miserable in my life so i'm like let me
just let me brighten my mood and read
about ancient egyptians
and um and it sent me down this rabbit
hole of like i'm like like there really
is a mystery i'm like any adult that
looks into this in the details the new
more nuanced details that they never
heard about in school or any documentary
unlike there is legitimate scientific
evidence that i say proves or at least
overwhelmingly indicates that there's
mystery there and it i'm like this is
awesome i'm like i'm not
debating you know the the the invasion
of the iraq war right now i'm debating
something really fun and positive that i
think
anybody could be interested in and i
came across then graham hancock randall
carlson i saw them on the joe rogan
podcast and it like exploded my head and
sent me further down um this rabbit hole
of of studying the ancients
and to me i think it's nothing more
it sounds funny to somebody it's the
sexiest topic ever it's the ancients we
don't know anything about it i'm like
it's fun
and it's just something about it just
gets me going the women were probably
the sexiest they were natural and they
had tons of jewelry
so going back to i grad i went back to
school for an mba i graduated in may of
16 moved to boise idaho for a whole new
start i'm applying at all these jobs
nothing's panning out and i was thinking
about becoming a school teacher i'm like
how am i going to do this i have student
loans like i can't afford to be a school
teacher like because i was thinking
about taking biting the bullying like
i'll just take the pay cut i used to
want to like make decent look if i got
student loans and i want to have a
decent car and like a house with some
land i'm like you got to make some money
i don't need i don't have any desire for
a mansion or a lamborghini but i do want
to be able to go to a restaurant and
order whatever i want i started at that
same period of time hearing that people
were making money on youtube i'm like
well hell i could teach anything in the
world on youtube
and that's what i started doing i
started shotguning it with topics of
spirituality i had videos talking about
crystals and intuition
and like near-death experiences
all kinds of stuff and the ancients was
the most fun topic because i would see
other videos like ah i could do better
than this come on now i'm like so i just
kept going at it i'm like all right you
know just listen to the feedback to an
extent and just get better and so like a
lot of people will see like my videos or
my channel be like oh wow you grew
pretty quick you know you only have so
many videos i'm like well i deleted more
than half of them and a lot of them
early on were terrible i wasn't
scripting myself i was all over the
place i would say things too many times
i was redundant i was annoying
and my editing sucks and um
anyway so it was a process and i'm
actually i'm just proud of myself
because i stuck it through and it was
worth it and i i just told myself ahead
of time i'm like well i'm not giving up
i'm gonna make my i had certain goals in
mind for it and i'm like i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna teach people
things that they need to hear because i
was thinking to myself i could go down
the uh the political route because at
that time we're talking 2016 all the
crazy stuff going in the world elections
and everything
and i was like i felt inclined to talk
about that and i've had to pull myself
back from politics because it only makes
me s it bothers it it ruins my mood
every time i look into anything did you
feel like you had something to say based
on having been
um in the army and having more
experience of the inner workings perhaps
oh yeah it if i'm being honest with you
the hardest thing has been for me with
my channel is that there are times i
really do want to expose and say things
i'm thinking because i see the world
right now and it's upside down and i
know what's going on there are big
things happening and they're not good
you know i'm very very concerned about
the direction of the future and if
there's anything i've learned while
studying the ancients is that there's
this reoccurring theme about our history
is that it's like a
we're constantly destroying ourselves
it's like a rinse cycle repeat of people
that
for some bizarre reason crave power and
want to exert it on others i don't know
why people are like this but they just
it's a human thing not all humans maybe
not you maybe not me but there's certain
people out there that are quite
miserable
and for some reason they
i don't know it just excites them to
have rule over others and make people's
lives misery miserable but anyway so
i do have this you know i've had it's
i've struggled greatly because i do see
things and i want to say it but i'm like
sometimes you have to choose a hill to
die on and some of the things i would
say i already know what would happen to
me or at least my my livelihood let's
say and so it's been difficult and i
remind myself i'm like well you do have
a hole to die on and i think that maybe
i'm better served because i just want to
live a happy life like it was a period
of time i was unhappy and i'm like
being happy feels good
so i want to live a happy life and i
think that one of i want to use whatever
skill sets i have to improve others
lives and like
ancients is a is a cool thing to do and
i do believe it's important because
there's something that happened and
we're gonna get into this there's
something to happen to the ancients
there's a reason why this it's so
mysterious
and i think that if we don't learn about
that it's just gonna happen again and it
would break my heart for us to have made
it this far technologically for after us
to go back to the dark ages and
and start over again and i fear that
that's possible if we don't learn from
the mistakes of the past so i think
that's a perfect lead-in to starting to
talk about some of these cycles that
have happened in the history i'm not the
best historian in general but i am
fascinated with so many different things
in life and so i tried to kind of
chronologically put in order some of the
ancient civilizations that
are hot topics
of
mystery whether or not they existed or
where it is and what it was all about
and of course
the main aspect that is the most
interesting is the technologies and just
how things were made and and what kind
of technologies they had you know
looking at ancient egypt and being there
and and to see where it's at in the time
frame that it existed and you go like we
couldn't even we'd have a hard time
doing that now you know like there's
things that will be difficult now that
they can't even figure out how to
engineer so clearly there was different
technology and the question of course is
who did that technology come from
and um so almost like closing the loop
from the very beginning when we started
talking about stars is you know one of
the things that's so common such a
common thread within so many of the
civilizations is their use of the stars
and especially orion's belts and the
three
the three stars of orion's belt and
those correlating with um with the great
pyramid and the other two um and then
that happens there's lots of there's
lots of other similar situations in
different places in the world so
if we're going back back back like
probably one of the most interesting
things that i think is getting more
more attention
um
more recently is the younger driest
period where you know there was
potentially a well no there wasn't
potentially there was a cataclysm there
was
something that hit earth
a comet an asteroid something like that
and
it
sent the world into
into
extinction essentially and they can even
find like
soot and ash and all kinds of things as
a layer in the soil to confirm this and
they learn all this through carbon
dating and things like that but the
younger drives period being about what
was it somewhere around 11 to 13 000
years ago so yeah yeah 11 600 is like
the onset is what they say well there
was a couple events and one happened
like 12 800 and then the other twelve
thousand six hundred so like in the
middle of it is the younger driest where
there's this deep cooling
and so like like you said like this is
like this is a this is scientific fact
what you have
is um as validated through uh core i
samples from um uh antarctica and
greenland which show that the earth went
through these cycles of extreme uh
heating and cooling um uh rapid thawing
of uh or rising of the global sea levels
because of thawing of the ice caps
more than 30 percent of the entire
earth's land mass is covered in that
soot you're talking about signature
traces of a cosmic impact including
nanodiamonds sphericals
melt glass iridium all traits that are
proven to have come from a cosmic impact
in fact
they even say that at that same period
of time there was global fires
they think larger than even the uh
during the impact event that uh was said
to have wiped out the dinosaurs and and
it's like and then with that came uh
a extinction level event this is just
north america
uh that i'm about to cite but 75 percent
of all mammals in north america went
extinct at that same period of time
um and they found like there's evidence
of a cataclysm they found woolly
mammoths with food in their mouths and
they're like knocked over and frozen
with their legs broken like something
poof them over a woolly mammoth a bunch
of them too and it's like something
happened and the evidence is there and
some people say this is like the
biblical legends of a flood that the
earth's sea levels rose
x amount of feet in a relatively short
period of time
most people lived on or near the coast
and it was like a essentially a reset
for whatever was going on before that it
was just
epic
hell on earth yeah
obviously um and the way that that plays
into it is kind of in some of the the
next
information which i know you've talked a
lot about
which is atlantis and whether or not the
disappearance
or the extinction
the the the sinking not the sinking the
covering up of atlantis happened at that
time when you came out of the younger
dryas and the ice caps melted and then
you know things were flooded so but i'm
wondering as far as like time timeline
goes
where do like because i was looking
stuff up because i was curious too i'm
like man how does this all fall in
because i thought of all the things that
i'm kind of curious about so i thought
about the on the anunnaki i thought
about sumerians egyptians mine culture
roman culture uh and atlantis and so
like that's actually the order in which
they came out as far as the order but
that so
where does atlantis come next in the
timeline or is it more
because or is it the anunnaki like do
what can we talk about the anunnaki yeah
let's do
there are some i'm going to make a video
on this there are some that believe that
the survivors of atlantis so if anyone
listening that hasn't heard this like
atlantis isn't just a disney movie it is
a legend that comes from the egyptians
and they discuss how and this is like
2600 bc and if they said 9 000 years
earlier there was an event that caused
the destruction of this advanced
civilization or by advance like people
should consider relatively means that
they were more advanced than what people
thought like it doesn't mean they're
more advanced than 2022.
um but anyway and
the the
date on that
is precise to the younger driest so to
me i'm like it's scientific evidence
that there was a civilization that got
obliterated because it's like it's too
much of a what a coincidence is that
there's some evidence that would suggest
the survivors of atlantis essentially
went and repopulated because they talk
about these seven sages so this is where
things get wild because i remember
looking into the story of atlantis that
came from plato we got from solon and
and he talks about like solon being the
wisest of the seven sages but it turns
out the sumerians had their own seven
sages and the sumerians are what we
believe to be
the one of the oldest
cultures or civilizations that we have
proof of
that's so according to the academics or
so yes that's the
that is the first known documented human
civilization um however we know and that
was before that about what year six
thousand six thousand years ago okay so
about four thousand bc
yeah yeah precisely and
so
and what's so wild in utah about
annunaki so to anyone not familiar it's
like some people suggest that beings
came from other worlds and created us
and gave us knowledge and everything
else and what's so wild about it is that
if you look at some of the earliest
tablets
the sumerian tablets
some of those i wish i could show you a
photo right now but they show like
these beings on like this bird-like
craft
sitting on it and people looking up at
them holding their hands up and i'm like
are they trying to like show us
you know is it like an alien spacecraft
so to speak and it's like there's some
weird stuff and they have this tablet
showing what some i think is the solar
system um
so it's like
yeah i mean this is taboo this is
conspiracy to some people they're done
of course we're not aliens it's like but
i'm like in my back of my mind i think
it's very possible because i think
humans are a very
weird species i think we're
i'll just say i think we're half alien i
think that something came here and
tampered with us and here we are people
think i'm wrong and crazy fine whatever
i don't care
i bet you it's true i can't prove it
that's so funny i i just posted a story
about the fact that they just hired
24 i think nasa maybe hired 24
theologians to study how the humans
would respond to aliens
aliens uh an alien encounter and my
friend sent me a message back and she
was like she was like we all already
know it just let everyone know you're an
alien
that you are that yeah by the way so um
undoubtedly there'll be people coming
from my channel
to like to your podcast to see this and
a lot of people so like i always knew
who you were to anyone listening like
like everyone recognizes you it's like
some people who wouldn't even know about
racing and so like i know this one it's
like you know i always knew who you were
and i thought you were doing awesome
stuff and then i heard you on the joe
rogan experience podcast back in 2018
and i was blown away because i was like
i i didn't know much about you but
everything i was just like wow like you
were
you're ice you're into these topics um
you're very conscientious you're very
inquisitive you're very sharp and um
there was just this whole other dynamic
to you that i think is legit surprising
because although
um
the rogan experience went over to from
you know youtube to spotify i remember
watching you on that program on youtube
and looking through the comments and
people
thousands of people were saying the same
exact things that i just said it's like
i didn't know this whole other side to
her and i would people so like maybe you
should maybe i don't know introduce
yourself a little bit because there's
people that are going to be
experiencing you for the first time that
don't know like that you have this whole
i mean you're just so interesting like
you're this like rare unicorn type
figure and that like you're the only
woman to do what you had done no you're
because you're rare like you you did
something that hadn't been done before
and and then you it's like you dropped
it all just a few years ago you were
tired you could have just kept going and
you were tired and you're like going to
pursue other passions and i think a lot
of people would have because a lot of
people just keep going and like i'll
just do this to the end and make all
this money and do whatever else so i'm
like
maybe i don't know introduce yourself
because people are going to learn of you
for the first time so oh yeah well
interesting i mean that's a that's a i i
agree i think sometimes people are
listening they don't necessarily know so
much history so to be quick like
obviously i used to be a race car driver
i did that for 27 years
and i would say that this sort of like
introduction into
spirituality probably came for me around
2014 15 maybe
and i mean i just remember getting
really fascinated going to sedona
i had always wanted to go to egypt
since i was a teenager um finally went
in 2021
and um like i just i i remember calling
psychics when i turned 18 i remember
buying linda goodman's love signs books
when i was a kid and could drive to um
back when people used to buy books at
stores called barnes noble and um
section and that's the only section that
was interesting to me
um and so i've just really always been
fascinated with the human experience
and i'm putting
mature words to it now but when i was
younger i just used to be curious i used
to just be like curious about things and
skeptical
so religion was probably the first thing
to come along that really what i was
skeptical about and it wasn't like i
didn't believe it it was just that i
just needed more information and so i
asked a lot of questions and so
um
and i remember one with the religion
that i asked a long long long time ago
and i was like why is it that you're not
supposed to have meat on friday during
lent like what is the significance of
that because people go through life
puppeting their way and like reading
repeating things and i'm like i want to
know why i'm doing this that's the point
i'm pretty sure and so when i found out
that it was because meat was a luxury
i was like oh well it's not anymore like
meat's not a luxury it's not something
that you can't find it's readily
available
so give up something that's a luxury is
the point and so um so anyway so i've
just always been a questioner and
um then i'd say towards the end of my
career i started to feel like an
energetic shift with my resonance with
my environment and so it wasn't like the
reason why my career uh why i why i
ended up retiring from racing um but it
played and it played a part like i think
that just kind of all happens once you
shift your frequency to a new level then
you know
you have to be ready for your new life
because it's going to cost your old one
and so there are things that tend to
shift or fall away or change that
that you wouldn't expect because it's
just not really in resonance with where
you are so i just remember being at the
track and thinking like wow people are
just not very happy and like i'm not
very happy and like i just couldn't feel
this like tension like
sad dynam like this it was just it's
just you know it's a sport so it's
competitive and you know it just wasn't
it just didn't feel good anymore and
even some of the people like didn't feel
right anymore and so then i just started
getting even more into videos and
watching you know
i love wayne dyer
and i love abraham hicks and i love
um i've i just started watching anything
that had to do with sort of spirituality
and
and um
you know what's really going on in the
world from a more from a more like a
quantum physics perspective i'm really
really fascinated with quantum physics
and how the nature of reality
um so then i just started diving into
that and then you know it kind of even
led to the like there was like a big
sort of like finale with my career where
it was like my career ended on a
sunday
i broke up with my boyfriend of five
years on a monday i moved out on tuesday
so i just it just didn't meet where i
was at anymore and so like my whole life
completely shifted and so it just kind
of sent me on this
sent me on this different direction that
was so it's so fascinating and um
i can't think of anything more important
in life than growing and evolving
and part of growing and evolving
requires you to question what's going on
right here right now and i think we're
in a deep deep immersion of that on so
many levels we're talking politically
personally
um uh health-wise
um you know reality i mean we're hiring
theologians to study how we're going to
deal with aliens and i think there's
just so many things that are being
revealed at this point in time um that
uh that are making people question the
way that things really are and the only
way that we really step forward is that
the truth emerges and it takes people
and energies and frequencies and and and
platforms to
you know shift that and to uh you know
reveal perhaps some of the other things
that are going on and it's not like the
stuff that we talk about today is going
to be some be all end-all of the answer
you know we're probably gonna have to
die to figure it out but we can start
pulling the clues together and we can
start sort of like you know it's the
house of cards when you pull the bottom
one we gotta start questioning it all
and so that's why you know i'm so
fascinated with this stuff and um
and i'm really just a big truth seeker
and uh yeah somebody asked the question
they're going to get the answer and i
think that's probably part of why people
um you know maybe liked me and were a
fan is that that i would answer the
question honestly when i know what's
real and what's not and what's then i
know more about what's important and
what's not and then when i know what's
important that means i can put my focus
there and i can help encourage myself to
live a better life where i'm happier
where i'm having more fun where i'm more
joyful where i'm less stressed out where
i'm not thinking about the past or the
future um that's why i do it so like you
had mentioned a moment ago about like
being you know quantum physics and all
that and spirituality like do you
consider yourself intuitive
oh for sure yeah i think that um
intuition is
one of those aspects that's being called
to up to to be developed within all of
us right now because there's not we're
not really sure where we're getting our
truth from anymore and so i think that
we need to develop that inner compass
and inner guidance
of our soul of our higher self of
god whatever you want to call it
um
we need to develop that that ability and
strengthen that muscle and so i think
that this is something
that the ancients probably did really
well is they had more of the power of
their mind to help shape what was going
on and um and i think that we need to
get back to that place again i mean you
know skipping ahead for a second to
egypt i mean it's all temples
it's all temples like there's yes there
are pyramids but they're completely
undecorated there's nothing they're just
i mean we'll talk about it when we get
there but the temples are like there are
so many of them and um and i you know we
will talk about what we think they were
but it just shows how much um commitment
and dedication to a spiritual practice
that they had that they would have so
many temples where so where do we follow
them with like anunnaki sumerians
atlanteans and and that whole dynamic
like what order did they come in and
then what led to the next thing
that's a good question i think let me
just say so i do
first of all think that we're like this
hybrid species and if that's true i
think it happened a really long time ago
but i don't know what that means i don't
know if that means hundreds of thousands
of years ago a million i really don't
know i had this feeling because we're
such this weird species we don't seem to
assimilate in our environment whatsoever
we look like a if you look at a city
from space it looks like a cancer spot
like we don't we
we need shoes just to go outside and
stuff like we can't even do anything
like we're this weird and we we're just
i don't know with this weird species
that destroys ourselves and
so like to answer your question i don't
know when that if that's true if that's
the case if you're like this hybrid
species and and by the way i don't even
i don't even uh dismiss um evolution i
think there's evidence of like things
are always evolving and adapting things
are always in a state of change so i
don't disagree with it i just think
there's more to the story but so to
answer your question i would say that
something happened
and then
maybe the sumerians or whatever we're
trying to
explain that but it's hard to say um
all i know is that the sumerians came
you know they were around
you know 1500 years before the egyptians
so-called egyptians started doing the
spectacular things like the the most
impressive pyramids say the pyramids of
giza whether it's atlanteans uh way
before them um because it's worth
mentioning a lot of people aren't aware
that the egyptians themselves same say
and this is uh inscribed on um the
temple of horus i believe um where they
say that the came from the island of the
primeval ones that had uh survived a
cataclysm and they repopulated down in
egypt and this kind of coincides with
what i'm researching now as far as the
sumerians talking about seven sages and
that the theory is that
people who survived that maybe this
pretended atlantis existed and they were
relatively advanced and doing cool stuff
some people survived if they got
obliterated by the cataclysm and they
went around to different places to
repopulate spread the knowledge i don't
rebuild yeah and
um so i think that there's truth to that
i i that would be my best bet the
atlanteans is proposed that that that it
that it flooded and that
some of those atlanteans you know were
able to
survive
and
repopulated in egypt then um on the nile
and that's where the the the story
continued it became from there on out it
was thousands you know or whatever
you're going to tell me how many years
later that you know that it became a a
metropolitan and um
and became what it is as what we would
know it today but um but the sumerians
were um
you know a part of that as well
where were where was samaria
so in the same exact region so if you
have egypt which is northeast africa
it's practically mid-east though it's
right there so if you go to like sumer
would be iraq
the mesopotamia which is the land
between two rivers between the tigers
and the euphrates it's all biblical and
it's still there and um it's super close
like it's i'm super close i mean
hundreds of miles but it's in the same
region like it's right there you're just
crossing some water i mean you can tend
to go up and go through israel and it's
all right there it's the same exact
region it's all now it's all big a big
desert
pit so to speak um it's all the same it
looks the same from space to me it's
there there is no separation they're the
same
you know especially when you look at the
fact that the samaritans are supposed to
be the alleged birthplace of
civilization and then that egypt which
was so impressive is just south and west
to it right there you your discovery of
atlantis
um where is that and what is it that
makes you feel like you know where it is
well let me say i haven't discovered
anything um because some people say that
i'm like i didn't i shared there was
this documentary yeah there's this
documentary from 2011 called visiting
atlantis by a george s alexander and
natalis rosen and this got like no
attention at all and i came across it
and basically they had proposed a theory
that a place something called the wrist
shot structure it's
r-i-c-h-a-t
it's in the western sahara of mauritania
so in africa
and it's 250 miles inland and it's the
most bizarre thing you've ever seen and
most people have never seen or heard of
it which is one reason what makes it so
bizarre
and in this little-known documentary
they proposed that this is the most
likely site for the lost city of
atlantis and atlantis was said to be a
kingdom or an empire made up of ten
kingdoms and then there was the the
capital and
they suggest that that was it because if
you look at it it's circular in nature
and it would have three rings of water
and two of land um which is exactly as
plato described it which is so unique
in itself because if you anyone just
google i it's commonly referred to as
the eye of africa and also the eye of
the sahara people call it different
things but reshot structure everyone
listen go google it right now and ask
yourself why have you never seen or
heard of this thing before so all i did
i i i popularized it and i built on top
of it i started digging in and i found
other corresponding evidence that i
believe strengthened the argument and
and i will say to be completely honest
i'm not 100 convinced but for me
it is the most likely uh
spot like there's more than a dozen
similarities with between the the rings
of water and tube land which is so
specific it's large enough to have how
uh home been home to millions of people
which atlantis would have been because
it was said to be busy all day and all
night spoken with different languages
from all over rich in trade
is said to be made up of black white and
red colored stone which is exactly what
you find all around the wrist shot um
uh it had elephants it was said to have
an abundance of exotic fruit and
the sahara desert a lot of people are
not aware that 5000 years ago it went
from being a lush green tropical
paradise to what it is now see most
people have no idea when i first learned
this and this is to be fair less than 10
years old the scientific data keeps
coming in
and it's like the sahara desert which is
the size of the of the continuous united
states
bigger than that actually
like was covered in the largest network
some of the largest network of rivers
ever known to exist and the largest
freshwater lakes ever known to exist and
now they're finding all kinds of bizarre
artifacts from unknown civilizations and
i'm like and this happened in
in possibly as little as a hundred years
about five thousand years ago that went
from green to desert and the way where
i'm going with that um is that okay so
that would have been rich in all kinds
of exotic fruit and vegetables um as
atlantis was said to have um and and i
made a few videos on this it's super
compelling again i'll be because i just
want to be because i'm an open-minded
thinker i don't know that it's it i will
say this though it is
like i said there's more than a dozen
similarities and it is uncanny it's
bizarre
and i think that it's the most likely
site um but i but in on top of that it's
covered in water erosion all across uh
the sahara this has been verified by
geologists um
the only debate is how long ago that
water erosion happened um there is salt
there which is indicative although not
100 proof that um the water or ocean had
settled there and i i bring that up
because some people will argue like
because i've
i made these videos a few years ago and
i've heard all i've looked into what the
critics have said i've studied in this
because i'm like let me see like am i
right am i wrong is there truth here
should i you know what let me i want to
know
and some people say no those are natural
salt deposits
i'm like huh
so
if this site was a geological
volcanic dome which is the scientific
consensus is that it was a volcanic dome
dome that
rose and uh and fell multiple times over
hundreds of millions of years or
whatever
are they suggesting that that's those
salt deposits were there before and
after all that volcanic activity because
uh no and i don't want to be rude but
like that's that's obviously not true
like that salt would have come after if
that whole thing was a volcanic
thing which i don't disagree with
um
then that salt would still be there salt
explodes when you heat it up like go go
go to your kitchen and put like a in a
frying pan some some oil and throw a
bunch of salt in there let me know what
happens like you know you've done it
right
so the point is i'm making that is that
i think it's very indicative that it did
come from the ocean um and i just say
that because some people like no no no
and i
anyways don't get me going on this um
well actually i mean
you're justified in that i mean like
even when you travel like i went to
egypt in 21 and
when you're when you're there you
realize that the front of all of these
temples they have these like ramps with
stairs inside the ramp and it was
because there was water all the way up
to them
yes water all the way up to him and when
you go to luxor and you go to the luxor
temple and you have you could there's a
there's a street there's a street that
connects to other temples way far away
and along the entire thing are
you know cats with different heads
and they're lined up the statues just
lined up all the way along the street
all the way down and they're finding
them because they were buried in sand
and dirt and everything because it had
been flooded and so you know when you
and and then of course there's
the sphinx and how you know there's no
way that it was built the same time
there's no way that it was built when
the egyptians were there and neither was
the pyramids probably but the but the
sphinxon particularly has um
uh water erosion that would require
substantially more than what uh egypt's
been experiencing for the last five
thousand years since it was supposedly
thriving and so
um it's there's so many things that the
water and the the temperature and the
climate of
um of it is is completely different in
fact i just did an interview with uh
alex honold the guy the free solo guy
and he was talking about how uh you know
obviously hiking and seeing things and
yeah he was talking about glaciers and
how sometimes when he's going to places
to climb he has to go in a different way
because the glaciers have receded enough
and so as he said like if the glaciers
stop
if they're not there anymore then
there's no more water then everything's
just gonna dry out and die if glacier
national park doesn't have a glacier
underneath it anymore it's going to dry
out there won't be humidity in the air
there won't be water to grow things and
um that's coming largely from the
glacier yeah and so this is one thing i
try to tell people like you need when
you look at these ancient sites like say
egypt you need to visualize what it was
like at the time because let's say like
we're just talking about the sahara
desert going from green
to desert 5 000 years ago approximately
and like well egypt's in the sahara
desert
and the fact that you were just
mentioning the sphinx has significant
water erosion
and that in the last time the nile delta
region had significant rainfall was like
more than 7 000 years ago so more closer
to nearly double the alleged age of it
and what that is is it's it's scientific
evidence that suggests that there was
water activity that shouldn't be there
and it's just it it suggests that the
things older and
um and like you were saying like the
nile river was once eight miles closer
went up to the pyramid steps and
the one thing i want to point out um
because like there is like so when it
comes to dating the great pyramid they
say it's like okay 45 4 600 years old
and um and they've dated it by finding
organic matter between the casing stones
and another piece of evidence was the
so-called uh khufu boat which was found
right next to it so like you're saying
the water went right up to the steps and
and one point i want to make is that
people should google
just type in giza boat and it's a 150
foot long thing it's awesome
but and i mean this with no disrespect
but it's a piece of sh it's a [ __ ] box
compared to the pyramid like if you look
at it it is
it is
so unsophisticated i mean it's better
than anything i could make it for me you
know but like to suggest
to suggest that the same builders
would could construct the pyramid and
then make that crap because it's said to
be coffery's boat oh this is the
the same alleged pharaoh that was said
to have um orchestrated the building of
the great pyramid of giza um
and that's supposed to be his boat um
and these are all just guesswork i don't
think it's actually true at all um but
the point that i'm making is that you're
really we're going to make the
comparison that the same people at the
same period of time that were making
this unbelievably sophisticated
structure one of the most impressive
structures ever made
and then they but they're like oh yeah
but we also make shitty boats for the
pharaoh i'm like
they were supposedly getting all of
their large stones to build it from a
quarry down the river and putting them
on a boat on like
500 miles away down the river anybody
else think this doesn't make much sense
and i know that's the way it flows it
does flow from the south to the north so
um up you know that's kind of upriver um
the south is up river um so the end of
it is down towards cairo where the with
opening where the the northern tip of
the of of egypt is in africa
but
there's no way there's no way and these
stones are like megalithic size and like
you know i mean let's just start diving
more into egypt now
um but
you know when you look at of course one
of the first stops that i made in on my
tour was to abadoz to
seti's temple and then to the assyrian
temple behind it which is like buried
it's not buried but it probably was kind
of at some point it's way below the the
seti temple and there yeah i believe
that the seti temple in abidos is
supposed to be one of the oldest
oldest yes
there is that correct i i
i'm not i think so i'd have to double
check but i said yeah three plus
thousand years old an old one and um
and and they they claim so anyone that's
like not familiar with this google
temple of seti study the first i believe
and then oh siri on o-s-i-r-i-e-o-n
i believe and uh google will bring it up
and they claim it's the same structure
the same temple but anyone looking into
us it's unbelievably different like the
assyrian is made up of these 60-plus ton
blocks
that are like 12 14 feet tall
um like eight feet wide they're
unbelievably big and we're said to have
been brought from hundreds of miles away
and i'm like these things each one of
them is heavier than
the abrams tank
and like i don't know if people
understand like that
like there's
it's unbelievable mass and um
uh and actually quick random some of
these stones that they find like whether
it's at uh because i don't want to
forget this i thought about a moment ago
i got the crpm some of these hundred ton
stone blocks came from 500 miles away
but some of them like the granite ones
the rose granite but some of the blocks
that they found huge stones found around
giza came from at least the only or
closest known location where there could
have been a quarry for that type of
stone would have like diorite would have
come from cyanide which is in the
eastern portion of egypt and it's in the
mountains so
like never mind for a second how they
would have brought these some of these
stones on boats that's one thing because
we never found the boat that could
support any of the weights on these
stones but we can come back to that but
if nothing else because some people like
well they had a bigger boat and you just
it's gone now so it's gone and that's
not proof it didn't exist i'm like fine
fine fine fine
but explain to me how they brought a 100
ton stone up and down hills in the
mountains and then across the river
i mean and from hundreds of miles or
maybe like less than like 150 something
miles whatever it is like explain that
up and down hills i'm like come on now
come on but anyways it's like the
craziness it's like the craziness of
mayan cultures and when you look at peru
and you go to
machu picchu and you look at they built
it like in the middle of these giant
giant mountains and then they just
created this
major structure civilization and you're
like how'd they get the stones for this
i don't know so my theory is that they
because when you look at the the casting
of these and i say casting
perhaps there was some way to melt the
rock they had some kind of frequency
that melted it um also when you look at
the um precision of like filling in all
the gaps and the little cracks and like
nooks and they're not just like block
block block with mortar in between all
of them they're fitted right up to each
other they have interesting little nooks
and different different little
characteristics that you're like why
would they waste their time with that
you know just make it a damn square
and i i think they had some kind of
frequency
technology
that um
was able to
dissolve these and be able to reshape
them
and probably the easiest thing to do is
to use what's already there on some
level perhaps like i don't know i i
don't know like i mean i guess i haven't
completely figured it out so i'll let
the scientists of the world know when i
come up with this crazy idea in my head
but but i think there had been something
like that because there's no other
there's nothing nothing else at least at
this point in time that makes sense they
surely didn't they surely didn't carve
them that way
you want to hear something wild yeah so
um so i was just in peru in august and
it was lovely by the way and um
so what i was told i never heard this
before
is that so according to the local
legends
they claim that
there was a certain plant that was
um
able to
soften the stone so it didn't like melt
it all the way down but it simply it
made all it facilitated that all these
polygonal shapes that are perfectly fit
together so and all right so this is
what it's plant
yes so no hold on so this is wild so
they ate allegedly
and then they saw it melt
right yeah
they envisioned it they imagined it so
allegedly there was these birds that
were living on cliffs and the locals
hundreds of whatever how many years ago
found that the birds were making nests
out of the same type of plant and then
the mucus or the whatever the
whatever it was from inside the plant
was essentially when it was set on stone
for periods of time it would essentially
soften it up and like deform it you
could like kind of like put a
fingerprint in it so to speak
and um this plant there was said to be
two different plants that could do it
and they were very high altitudes now
this doesn't exist anymore but what i
saw i went over there thinking they had
like advanced machine cutting or late
and i'm not saying lasers but it looked
like laser light like if you go to a
laser-like precision if you go to like
soccer oman you have these 120 plus ton
blocks fit together perfectly
that today would be like a laser you
would think and um and i looked at it
and i'm like it really opened my mind
i'm like i think they did have an
ability whether it's a frequency or a
plant that was say eradicated by the
spaniards i mean that could be possible
whatever it was
something's missing and the one thing i
want to point out
because if there's one theme to my
anything i'm doing with this ancient
stuff is i wanted to share to people
like there's a real mystery here that
some people
have it in their minds like i used to
which is that well if it's not on the
news it's not true or i would have heard
about it if it was true being the front
page so you know next you know can't be
bothered
and the reality is that if you dig into
this stuff you'll see that there are
unbelievable mysteries for example um
i'm sure you went to oyante tombo it's
like that other
combo or whatever yeah it's hard to say
but i did go there i went to a i went to
a ruins there too
yeah yeah so
did you go did you go to the top did you
climb up all those like 1500 stuff yeah
yeah it's a huge there's almost like it
seems like auditorium style
levels
it's probably terraces where they i
think they farmed as what they said yeah
yep and at the very top did you notice
it's like sesame street one of the
things is not like the other did you see
those massive 80-ton blocks at the top
like those huge huge huge megalithic
stones let's ring a bell
i guess there was a structure up there
but yeah okay that so
that
those same stones are known and this is
like not debatable uh on the mountain on
the other side there's a river right
there but two miles away there is a
quarry and i even measured this on
google maps like because i was told this
when i was there on a tour and i came
home and did my own little fact checking
and sure enough the the quarry where
that same type of granite came from was
across the valley two miles away over a
river and up like 12 000 feet up so even
thousands of feet higher so this to
bring these 80 ton stones we would have
had gone downhill across a river you
know a couple thousand feet again
80 ton stones i'm like this is like not
efficient that's just not efficient like
why wouldn't they listen to something
else
i know and here's another thing i've
been dying to share so okay
because like the experts will say well
they would have how cause they feel like
how did they move these stones like well
we would have rolled them over on logs
i'm like okay well that's possible but
here's here's what's so wild
the largest native
tree in all of peru i forgot the name of
it because it's a very exotic name i
have many photos of it
first of all it's particularly small and
none of the branches grow straight none
of them none of the the original the
trunk it's all bendy it's a very unique
body they can't roll it
no and and people will say because they
have an abundance of i believe it's
eucalyptus trees uh i think it was from
australia is that the big the tree that
comes from australia
i think it's eucalyptus if i'm getting
that wrong well either way in the
so the bar the biggest trees now are
like you know they're 100 feet tall
and there's like a bunch of them there
in peru um but
and and the experts will say well yeah
see they use these trees
for welding them on logs but it's not
until you dig into the details that
those trees were brought over from
australia in the 1860s did not exist
it's not native of peru i'm like what of
course like it's fun to dive into
mystery but also
it just trying to help encourage people
start questioning things question things
you know it doesn't mean that everything
out there is fake but it does means that
some probably is and i think that we can
all agree that there's some [ __ ] out
there that's not real and our history
has been
covered or left out and you know
just to like intermission perspective
it's because
obviously i think that we have so much
more capacity and power as a human as a
human being it's like even when we think
about a.i and all those crazy things
going on we're like oh man they're going
to replace us they're
you know they're going to be
technologically advanced it's like all
of their information is still coming
from humans
so you know imagine if we were able to
trust and believe and cultivate our own
you know our own
capabilities that go beyond just like
collecting data what about manifesting
what about moving something with your
mind i had this crazy dream as like a
side story too i had this crazy dream a
couple of years back where i was um
i was
in this basket it was like a basket that
was kind of small it was almost like the
size of what a hot air balloon would be
but there was no balloon and in this
basket you
could go wherever you wanted to go
in an instant like the basket moved and
so it had anti-gravitational levitation
and it would and it was
and in the activation
there was essentially so i was like oh
man how does your hair not get wind
blown when you go like million pounds an
hour going somewhere first question yeah
it was yeah my hair and so um it was
there would be like a force field or
like an energetic sort of bubble around
it that would protect it from protect
you from the elements and so anyway i
later on after i saw that video
i was looking this is within a month a
month couple months after uh looking on
instagram and there was this there was
this video that had popped up on one of
my follows and it was a basket that used
some beetle technology to levitate and
it would just zoom all over it like 800
miles an hour
and i was like no
[ __ ]
so what about obviously so anyway i'm
just like trickling that into a funny
little ridiculous story maybe not
ridiculous but how did they get the
stones there were they able to levitate
them move them
it probably makes a lot more sense than
rolling them down trees i went to uh
stonehenge in england and they said the
same thing that they they somehow got
these huge huge i mean
like when we say huge they're just
you have to really be in person to
appreciate that um but they said they
came from hundreds of miles away and
it's like but why
but why would you do that why would you
waste and spend all your time with the
technology that we think they had
to just like wheel them on over here to
build this like
design it's like art like obviously it
had a high purpose they obviously didn't
roll them or anything like that they had
some other technologies
so when we think then about like how the
pyramid was built like
man i mean when when i was at karnak
they said see how this mound of dirt is
here and you can see the separation the
gap between this wall and the next wall
and that that mound was basically built
up so that it would keep building they
just keep building the what what the
sort of mound up and they'd ramp up the
rocks to build the temples
and
like obviously there's some remnants and
some ways that some of that could have
happened
possibly but we're talking about the
great pyramid of egypt and we're talking
about something that's how tall is it do
you know
481 feet at its height which is i've
told this to other people before but you
live in arizona like me so you are of
course familiar with the chase tower in
downtown right yeah you know the tallest
building in arizona is the chase tower
it that i believe is like 483 feet so
we're talking basically identical so the
great pyramid would be as
tall as the tallest building in all of
arizona and not to mention 755 feet wide
at each of its bases and so when they
talk about like this ramp theory you
would literally because people have done
the math on it you would literally need
more stones or as many that made up the
entire pyramid itself and you extend
like a half mile out like because like
if you get to a point where you get 10
grade every physicist like there's no
you're not moving those 70 ton blocks up
that so like okay so the
this is the consensus this isn't like
jimmy like guessing like this is like
okay well how did they do it 70 ton
blocks more than 120 of them uh you know
more than 300 feet up inside the
alleged kings chamber and all that
so it's like okay so if they did the
ramp theory which isn't um
that's not a bad theory at all like it's
like okay like if they're gonna get
these stones up they're like i you know
a ramp theory is not bad but then you do
the math on it's like well if they
needed more stones or as many as it
would take to build up the entire
pyramid well then where are those stones
now and i could say well okay uh i use
those for the next pyramid cool okay but
then what where are those stones like
for that you know what i'm saying you do
next next next and i'm like
yeah no that's a that nah i
i don't know how they did it and i i
it makes me
i feel proud to say i don't know because
there's a lot of people out there that
say we do know this is how and i'm like
okay well that's there's no you can't
prove that so to say you know is that's
not honest um you see sawyer walking
around can you hear him walking are we
good sorry you see you feel really good
cute
i don't know how to walk them out
is that a dog
oh that's about here come here yeah so
here um because you gotta hold on let's
see come here
say hi everyone likes dogs hey i have a
policy never and trust me this is good
life advice never trust anyone that
dislikes dogs
i hear you it's one thing if they don't
if they don't want to own one because
they travel and they just don't whatever
but i'm talking about people who like
like you want that dog
don't trust those ones
i'm not supposed to
which makes me think cats were a huge
thing in egypt too like i mean like the
woods were a huge thing why are why were
cats such a big deal in
in ancient egypt you know i that's a
really good question and actually so it
wasn't just cats so like i remember
seeing this is like an article i don't
know a year or two ago where they found
this crypt the subterranean burial uh
cemeteries or so uh in egypt for pets
and in it was more than
two million dogs and cats mummified
yeah they the egyptians so as far as
cats like they do seem to be
i don't i almost felt like they leaned
towards cats but the same time there was
anubis the dogs so i'm like exactly i
think they're both and i to me
i look at and i don't care people think
i'm crazy i look at dogs and cats as
spiritual beings um especially sawyer
over here like
he
feeds off me so i could be really
stressed like i could if i'm like
looking at my laptop and he's in the
other room this has happened so many
times where
i'm like feeling like my blood starts
you know i'm start like i'm stressing
about something and then i'll hear him
whimper in the other room
and like i'm like he senses it because
he'll do it in front of me but then it's
happening times we're in the different
room and it's not like me breathing loud
and i'm talking like i'm seriously quiet
i'm looking at something i just came
across i'm like oh damn it like in my
head and then i also hear whimper i'm
like
because i've heard other people refer to
dogs as psychic um buffers
for the for the spiritual realm and
and
and i was going to say along with that
the same thing with cats because
i used to say i'm not a cat guy but i am
now i don't own a cat i only ever get
one if i have a property so it can be an
indoor outdoor cat
um
but um i've noticed that in my life as
like i've chilled out over the years
um more and more stray cats come up to
me and it happened a ton in egypt where
some people got scratched by cats the
same cat would come and be friends with
me and i have videos of this i was going
to post on instagram but i want to be
like a lame-o and post it um but i was
like i made a lot of friends with cats
and i feel like it's because i was out
there with this really non-predatory
mindset this very
in my predatory i mean like just
you know like a lot of people a lot of
stray animals won't go up to certain
people because they're in their own
heads and they're they're giving off
this vibe of like stress but if you're
just chill and really happy they seem to
gravitate towards you because i've known
people in my life that animals just love
them i'm like what's going on here like
what is it like
like
animals like you yeah yeah they do yeah
yeah i'm sure you made friends with the
uh the cats at and aswan at the uh it
wasn't at the isis temple but at there
was another temple
that we went to
maybe it was just right on the river was
the one on the river there was the cats
they're very friendly there to to people
in general and it was real friendly to
me and then all of a sudden it bit me
and i was like wow what does that mean
um but anyway um was it from what does
this mean sometimes they nibble some
cats are a little aggressive and they
mean and they're friendly some cats
don't know any better because they're
not domesticated was the cat mean to you
it's just the swipe is the bad thing a
bite might not be bad anyway back to
egypt and back to some because there's
just so many things that i'm just so
curious about your perspective on um
so there's there's the stones and like
not to mention we're talking about how
to get the stones there but then also
the outside of the pyramids was smooth
and shiny
perfect and perfectly smooth and shiny
it doesn't look like that now but it was
and also
there were tops to the pyramids
so i'm curious what you think
the top was made out of what you think
the purpose of the temple was and then
also just to like one final piece of
like
having been there and going through
going through the
tunnels and the yeah and the inside
pyramid the shafts and the stairs and
all that like everything on the inside
was definitely like i mean there's no
decorations it looked like it was meant
for acoustic purposes
it um but it was um
it also had some very small passageways
and some very tall ones um but anyway i
how do they carve that into the stone
how do they plan ahead on that i think
they probably had to have some sort of
like cutting not cutting but like
frequency
device that had to have been able you
have to go in after they had to have
gone after they had to run in after to
like carve the design
or add or something like that but anyway
give me your synthetic
what the hell the the pyramids are all
about and what they were used for and
all about the top that doesn't exist
anywhere other than there is one what's
that called there's a there's one top
left i can't remember the name of it
right now but they haven't then they
moved over to the moment
the bin bin
something like that yeah i don't
remember
actually a quick little story on the bin
bin top and then i'll let you have it um
is that one of my friends ray and i were
you know were at the museum and the bin
bin top is there and so she had this
intuition that she could
feel me through the rock and so for
people who don't know the bin bin rock
was is made of materials that's not
found on earth so there's like a lot of
materials in it that are not found on
earth
so anyway so she was like okay put your
hand on it
and think of a body like just like think
of a body part and so
she so she put her hand on the rock all
right our hands were on the rock and
then we just sort of closed our eyes and
let it happen
and um
and the first place i'm now i'm
forgetting like it was maybe my
something foot or something like that so
she was energetically pushing energy to
a part of me
kind of
yeah like a reiki kind of thing and so
she get so the first one was right and
then the next one was totally right too
and we just both stopped and we were
like oh my god that was so crazy like
something like that to me like that's
something i would never forget for the
rest of my life and i always wonder like
how is that possible like it's to me
because you can't prove it to someone
else but when you experience it then you
know it's real it's like seeing is
believing so to speak so of course we
were all taught that the pyramids were
built to be tombs for the pharaohs
and i really want to emphasize to people
that that theory did not exist until the
latter part of the 1800s at that period
of time britain controlled egypt they
quite literally invaded um they had
authority there um
a lot of people don't realize that egypt
has been
absolutely conquered
at least several times like anything off
the top of my head but like who knows
the other lost history there
um so i just want people to know that
the only
there is absolutely no almost no
evidence to even suggest that the
pyramids were built to be tombs for the
pharaohs or anybody as you were
mentioning besides the fact there's no
decorations they never found a single
mummy in any pyramid ever which
surprises every time i tell that to
somebody i mean like oh you know i tell
them like i'm talking ancient history
and i mentioned that and they're like
really like yeah
um the internal structure and layout is
so utterly bizarre that to me i believe
that it was functional i do not think
that the pyramids were built to be tombs
and i know that sounds crazy to some
people first because like well what is
it
we mean functional like it's a stack of
bricks like we talking about
and i i just generally i'm just sharing
what i think i think it's above us that
they were some people back in time were
more advanced than we are today
although that's not to say that we're
not more advanced than them as well i
think that there's just different
realities that can exist at any point in
time in in in
like if you were to get a bunch of
humans and put them on a bunch of
different planets and come back
however many years later i would i'm and
assuming they didn't get obliterated by
the elements or whatever and just got a
chance to really just thrive you know
what i mean like they're fed and they're
secure and they're just allowed the
human ingenuity to to
carry on i bet you each individual
civilization would be doing
things that the other civilizations one
thing's possible and vice versa that's
what i think i think this is how humans
work
um and i think that's what happened back
in the day and i i suspect that the
pyramids were some sort of energy device
and i say that because the nile river
once went right up to it and i when i
think of like the largest structures on
earth today like hydroelectric dams
that's for producing electricity and
when you look at the fact that the nile
river once went right up to the steps
i'm like
and there's a subterranean chamber some
have philosophy or or suggested that
theorize i should say
that
it channeled water and did something um
and and
i don't know though like what i do know
is that i walked through it and knew i
was in the presence of greatness and
there was not a single thing about it
that to me
resembled a tomb because i went to the
valley of the kings i went through the
moustabas all around the giza plateau
which are known burial sites
and
there's not a single similarity at all
except
that empty those empty sarcophagi boxes
inside the alleged king chambers of each
so okay maybe they were
there's a few possibilities there either
they
later on were used to be kings for
somebody which is totally possible um
where those boxes were once something
else like in the in the king's chamber
it almost seems to me that that was
something else and then was carved out
because the um you went in the you had i
don't know of course you did you went in
the great pyramid king's chamber right
chamber queen's chamber and subterranean
did you did you lay in the box i did i
was gonna ask that i did i l i toned in
the box we all did your chance yeah yeah
is that wild
for people who don't know what toning is
it's just honestly like
do it
yeah like
i can't do it yeah you're just
toning it's just like sounds it's uh so
anyway we all had an opportunity to lay
in it and did you too you did it so i
was with the tour and i was really
polite the whole time and that everyone
cut in front of me and like because i
didn't want to be mister because i was
there with my camera and i was there to
take pictures
and then it was the surprise that you
were able to film in there they told us
we couldn't
i know they did our private visitation
of the great pyramid was from three to
five a.m it was oh wow holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] was that like it was a full moon
full moon in leo
and it was it was stunning it was so
bright to be able to walk there because
it was a full moon
i was in there for we had a two hour um
and it was at like six to eight p.m so
what i had done was i had me and a buddy
i literally sprinted and ran in front of
the entire group of like 30-something
people i ran and i got in there first
and i had
about almost three minutes alone in
there the great pyramid king alleged
king chamber totally alone
and it was like that was a special
moment for me because i was like i did
it i made it here like i'm here like i'm
like i was literally like i don't know
if i pinched myself but i remember
thinking like pinch pinched like holy
[ __ ] jimmy made it and not only did i
make it i'm there alone it was and then
i laid in the box by myself and i
remember just looking up and like and
one of the things that stood out more
than anything was the acoustics that
even the my breath the echoing i've
never experienced
sound reverberation like that right it
was next level insane because even if
you're having a conversation it's like
echoing i mean you know like it's like
but like at a level i've never i don't
even know could be possible it was crazy
and um
yeah i just i just knew i was in the
presence of greatness i remember looking
around at all the precision of these
huge 70 cup ton stone blocks that were
fit together perfectly without any type
of mortar
and and just thinking to myself like
what i knew i was confused in there i
was like i don't know what this is but
it's something else and nothing about it
i didn't have any burial chamber vibe to
it at all and i know some people listen
to this like okay who cares about your
vibe i'm like it just wasn't
i just don't i don't believe it i would
bet my i would bet
i bet a limb on it and if i end up
losing an arm in the process i would be
utterly shocked i would be shocked
because i i do i genuinely believe and
it's not just a feeling it's like if you
really research every argument you can
hear about the pyramid on being a tomb
and otherwise or other theories as well
that are alternative
yeah i lean way against the the barrel
thing i'm like now it's something else
because okay you know when you went you
go down so here's the thing a lot of
people don't realize that when they
think of the pyramids they in their own
minds because they're not familiar with
the layout
they assume or think that it was like
this maze uh to hide the pharaoh you
know the tombs and you know it's like
this complicated structure it isn't you
go down
and then you go up and then you're there
there's no there's no like zigzag left
and right where do i go from here like
no like if this was meant to hide
pharaohs which they claim i'm like well
then all i did is go down and up and i'm
here um but that part aside remember how
you went you you go down and then when
you get into that so or you go up excuse
me uh you first go down then you go up
into the uh you get that grand gallery
excuse me we're about to go up and you
know how they have those wood planks
that you walk up it's kind of like
stairs
you should see pictures of it without
those that would there it's a slide it
is a i was going to ask is it like a
tube almost it's like well it's actually
it's rounded because the top is really
um there's like it's like a reverse it's
kind of it's a pyramid inside and
there's almost like staging um
into the ceiling yes it looks like it's
acoustically designed it's not just flat
there's actually like purposeful edges
and ridges that are symmetrical and go
it looks like it's meant for
for frequency energy acoustics something
like that i totally agree no it's not
decoration it's functional um and if you
see it without that wood there it's a
different you get a
i'll have to send you a picture after um
because like these pictures are very old
they're black and white because those
stairs have been there forever those
planks but when you see it without it
you get this but this way
the vibe i get by looking at it without
those stairs there you would think it
funneled water and um
one of the gentlemen i met um on this
the the first time i went this guy is a
brilliant so he's a president of an air
compression uh uh company in canada and
he's a brilliant man he's like i would
say high iq
very nice guy as well and he came there
you know inclined to think he's like i
think there's more to this story here
but i'm gonna i'm gonna come look and
he's very he's an inventor like mine
and um and he had some very interesting
thoughts he's like it feels like this
place or his sense is that it's meant to
keep massive amounts of energy in just
the very layout of itself and he's like
when i look at different things that we
do with compressors just air um he's
like you know he's like it's not
irrational to suggest that if air and
water had been moved through it you
could create insane
amounts of pressure and if you have
high pressure you can do anything with
it you can make that's energy itself
like even um um the titanic like all
right so that's primitive like it's a
steam engine um the whole that 50 000
tons of iron that they were pushing it
you know 20 plus miles an hour through
the ocean
um was done
only just through a bunch of built up
pressure through steam through heat they
like throwing wood in the fire
yeah yeah right like in the scene in
titanic they're stoking the fire
try to tell them to leave because it was
so hot and steamy and it's just you know
that heat and heat creating it yeah some
smart people i met on these tours from
all over the world that were there with
open minds and like some of them were
even going they're thinking well it's
probably teams with me let me just see
and like they left egypt being like
like they're like oh my god like like
something was happening here on earth it
was really impressive and like and it's
beyond you know just beyond it's like
it's something it's gone but the mystery
is there and like to some people who i
looked up to
let me just say let me speak for myself
actually i went there
to egypt and it confirmed what i was
already highly suspicious of which is
that something spectacular was happening
on earth that humans were doing amazing
things
but i'm like i need to go and look see
with my own eyes touch some things and
kind of just get a feel before i like
you know and
then i'll know and it confirmed it
whether it's the assyrian for sure um
the the sierpin with the center time
boxes the great pyramid and everything
else i'm like okay we haven't even
talked about the temples which is what
we're going to talk about next but
i mean i'm with you there's clearly
something else i hadn't thought of the
water element but i mean when i was in
the great pyramid and i was in the
king's chamber i mean the one thing that
i feel like i can sense
um
is frequency
so like just the resonant frequency
so like i hate emfs like i have em i
took wi-fi out of my bedroom area okay
emf reducers i have like
an emf anti-radiation phone case i've
had it forever
um how do i get one of those is that on
amazon
the safe slaves the company they they're
great um
and they make blankets even now
radiation blankets so anyway i feel like
i can feel that that's kind of the one
thing i can feel um really feel like
pretty well and um so this kind of plays
into even interpersonal like if like i
can feel if there's truth and resonance
with the with another person in me and
with their telling like just there's a
frequency to everything and so that's
yeah yeah on lots of levels so
um but in the great pyramid in the
king's chamber the frequency was really
high so my opinion is is that it was
used as like
um energy centers i just think they were
energy centers i think that perhaps they
were used for healing
um perhaps they were used to somehow
sort of charge up in some kind of ways
even to rebalance and you know maybe
there was some kind of i don't know
communication with
other extraterrestrials maybe that's
where it happened
um because of the alignment with um
orion's belt and the pyramids and and
the way that they use the stars perhaps
as sort of like a almost like a like a a
direction it's like directions it's like
a yeah it's like oh yeah it could be
landing here
like we're here yeah ping ping like land
here come come and get us hey hey alien
overlords that dropped us off and left
us come back and get me
yes perhaps i'm i'm ready although i say
that and then i walk out at night to let
the dogs out and i'm like i'm ready i'm
not ready i don't think so
like the idea the actual idea of it is
like far like if it was really gonna
happen is a little bit more scary
although i believe that there'd be
benevolent beings and they would
probably make me feel comfortable like
in the movie contact when jody foster
meets her dad on the beach and he looks
like it's her dad but it's really
actually just an alien or an
extraterrestrial and um they're like we
thought this would make it more
comfortable for you i'm sure they could
shape shift into whatever would make us
comfortable
i love that movie by the way some people
like some people diss that movie i'm
like you're dumb i'm like this movie's
too smart for you it's brilliant i love
it i love it but that's definitely what
i think and then perhaps maybe the tops
were made maybe the tops came from
extraterrestrials maybe they were like
maybe they were um
sort of like the conduit or conductor to
to the structure
um
but you know we're probably going to die
to find out but that's those are our
theories now i'm kind of curious what
you think about the temples because they
had a lot of thoughts about the temples
and um i highly recommend people to go
and see them because they're absolutely
stunning every square inch of temples
from
uh the pillars to the ceilings to the
walls
everything is covered
in
hieroglyphs in stories in pictures
and um it's it's just really stunning
and as we touched on earlier for a
second that the um egyptian culture has
been conquered many times um it's really
sad to see how the romans came and
chipped off like the hand the feet and
the heads yeah basically like everything
the faces and the feet and stuff got
chipped off in in in so so so many
temples and it's it's really sad because
yeah you think about these guys just
like
slaving over and trust me some of them
are so high right like they're so high
up there and they're on ceilings and
they're obviously spending their days
just being [ __ ] and chipping faces
up so
anyway the temples what did you think of
those and what did you think um they
were used for there's a bunch of temples
a lot of people don't realize in egypt
how many temples are but my absolute
favorite and and where it was many
people's favorite um the temple of hot
tour it is it's in dandera and it was my
absolute favorite i have not been to the
yeah isn't that is your favorite you
said it's that's my favorite i mean i
love the isis temple but as we talked
about um it has been moved and there's
just some essence of it that doesn't
feel the same because it was under water
and they they were able to lift it and
move it to dry land now it's still
stunning um but uh dendera um or hath or
temple was just
unreal and there's so much blue in it
still it's it's yeah how did that paint
survive and like so i have i have not
been to italy unfortunately um but i
have friends that were with me in egypt
that have been to the sistine chapel
and this gentleman um let me give a
shout out to george howard he's awesome
he's one of the uh he was a scientist
one of the original younger driest
papers brilliant man fun to travel with
and uh he was there i was with him and
he said he'd been the sistine chapel and
he's like this place dwarfed it he's
like this place like to him he's like
this eclipsed it that was his work it's
like this eclipse is it they're both
impressive but this place was some
there's just those huge columns and i
don't know what it was like 80 feet high
at least 60 feet but maybe 80 feet like
it was the ceilings were all the way up
there and um and not only that it had
this wonderful vibe like i i i'm big on
vibes like funk's way is a real thing
like
whether it's me adding plants into my
house or like you know
different places like whether i go to
like um a restaurant or like a wine bar
with friends or something i'm like some
places
feel better than others yeah you're not
just sensing energy you're just feeling
frequency baby
yeah
so what did you think that what was the
energy for you in there i have my idea
of what i thought the energy bliss it
was blissful me i was obviously yeah
like this place is is i i could like
live there i'm like this place was
lovely i'm like this i thought it was
super playful i thought it was super
playful i was like picturing myself
running around and playing and playing
hide and go seek in there i was like
this place is fun
it was like a really fun place to be
like it had just a really good
good positive blissful fun energy
and and like you were saying like from
like floor ceiling to or to ceiling is
every inch practically covered in glyphs
spectacular glyphs like you've seen that
blue still in there like anyone
listening type in go to google images
and type in uh temple of hot tour h
the pictures will bring it up but i was
gonna say the ceiling alone
um but you know one of the things that
really really really got me about that
place is you know are you are you
familiar with the so-called light bulb
um glyphs that are down in that
subterranean portion like there's these
certain glitches
because this is one of those things that
fascinated me is that that i wanted to
talk about was how there's i don't know
how they saw anything i don't know what
kind of light they use because we've got
these wires and lights all over the
place so that we can see but i'm sure
that they did not freaking use those
back in the days and i don't know how
they got how they saw anything because i
don't i didn't see any hieroglyphs or
anything that would indicate light
other than perhaps maybe the ankh was
some form of it because there was
something
but i did not what did you see
well okay so a couple things let me tell
people that um
first of all in some of these
subterranean areas where it's pitch
black without any of our lighting like
danica was just saying like this is like
we've rigged up these shitty lights like
you got this cords everywhere it's it's
not
witty whatever yeah and but what's
missing is soot from when you use
lanterns or torches so like for example
the sistine chapel i forgot what year it
was it was like i want to i'm just
guessing let's say latter part of 1800s
where they did restoration and they had
hundreds and hundreds of years of soot
on it from light and torches
and they cleaned all that up like so all
those magnificent paintings that people
see on the top of the ceiling of the
sistine chapel was restored because it
was covered in such like people need to
understand that that smoke that emits
from whether it's a candle i'm not
talking about your little fun wax candle
from yankee candle company but like
we're using legit um flame for lighting
especially over the last number of
hundreds of years it takes in a short
period of time you get black soot that
just sticks to the ceiling it's really
gross yeah um and there's none of that
there
zero and and and it's not because
they've restored it like you can
research it there just never was and
so you go to this one area and like as
you were describing a few minutes ago
how all the faces are destroyed
um and there was this one little section
that do you remember crawling down in a
corner of a little room you go down and
there's this little and you have to like
i nailed my back on it and you don't
talk about you went down and then
there's this long you turn it
it's kind of towards the back of the
temple and then you go down it's in a
room there's like an opening that you go
down some stairs and then you kind of
twist around and down and crank around
and then it goes both directions they
called it like for us they were kind of
like
giving us this sort of like overview of
the temples and like they were saying
that was kind of the birthing canal so
whatever but it was completely dark it
would have been completely pitch black
absolutely no natural light could have
got in there yeah so you know it's wild
and i have video of this um
just all right so that was one of the
places that was off i forgot what year
they discovered that i want to say
there's a lot of part of the 1800s when
like it may have been i don't know if
petri or vice or whoever but either way
the people that originally went through
and ransacked and and destroyed the
faces they didn't find that spot because
it was covered so if you actually go
back and look at it and i'll have to
post this video online i haven't i've
been sitting on it um in that corner you
go to get down in there it was a granite
block it was completely this is a hidden
passage people like this was meant to be
kept secret and it was because the
vandals that went through there
never found it because the place is
pristine and so you have to move this i
couldn't even tell you how heavy this
big ass granite block that was a flaring
tile and when you move that this thing
was locked shut so like people had to
eventually break in there and then you
get into this room covered in total
glyphs all over the place and one of
which is the so-called light bulb now
let me just say i don't think it's a
light bulb but it looks like it and if
you type in egypt light bulb and then
you know you're going to see it and
and you're talking earlier because this
is one thing that came to my mind you're
talking about like yeah um i forgot how
you worded it but like us being i forgot
how you worded it but basically there's
these weird faces and there's like four
or five of them and there's it's like
this thing on their head and it's like
this this string coming out attaching to
this weird looking
device it's like these people's heads
are connected to something and i'm like
i think they're trying i don't know what
they're trying to express the way it was
explained to me with like that alleged
light bulb thing um
it was explained to me that essentially
it's it's showing them harnessing
it's he said it's more
impressive than even a light bulb
because within that knowledge that
they're trying to show you is the power
of the universe and how you can create
all things and that all things that have
been created it's showing you that
that's where it came from and some
people say oh it's earth and this is the
this is the stars and the cosmos there's
all kinds of different ways to interpret
it
but what i will say is this
is this it no that's not the light bulb
one but that's right on the that is what
i was just describing to you so the
answer is yes the light bulb thing is
just a few oh hang on is that same wall
yeah that's that's yes that's the
alleged light bulb thing
oh and they say like oh that's just the
bottom portion is um osiris's uh
backbone and it's a blah blah blah i'm
like okay that's not what it is um i
think they're literally showing you the
technology the one with the lines is a
jeb
yep um and then it's almost to me that
looks like
to me i'd think it was more like i don't
know it looks like sperm
kinda yeah actually yeah cause it's like
snakes almost so when you look at that
right so what i think i'm looking at is
something very impressive it could be
technology or it could be showing you
harnessing
the universe itself for technology i
mean it's very complicated and there's
so many different thoughts in this and
some people are convinced they're
showing you a light bulb and all these
other things all i know is that that
knowledge this is the point i want to
make and especially that first picture
you showed of like all those heads
connected to that thing i'm like what
the like that's really weird and
the port the part that i want to
emphasize to people like they hid this
[ __ ]
this is underground in a secret passage
that was kept hidden for thousands of
years and even vandals that went through
over millennia to try and wreck this
place never found it they purposely put
it in a crypt-like situation where again
i'm gonna have to upload this video
because it's like jimmy's home video on
his iphone and it was so funny but um
you hit me like you hear me hit my back
and i'm such an idiot it's so funny but
um anyway so like you go down in there
and i'm like this place is secret and
and and this the most bizarre glyphs
i've ever seen out of anything from
ancient history are in that spot and
just look at it and think for yourself
people like you go and research what the
mainstream says about it you should
definitely do that um but just look at
things for yourself and tell me that
you're not it's like they're trying to
preserve information and they put it in
a spot that would never be or i
shouldn't say never they put in a spot
that was meant to be kept safe well
they're so so supposedly there are
tunnels they haven't like found them all
but they're
the idea is that they they have tunnels
all over connecting everything like
there's an underground tunnel system
going all around um especially within
the temples themselves but i had an
overwhelming feeling that these temples
were like i thought about it and i
thought about our own temple and they i
felt like they were used for
our own introspection into ourselves and
our power and i feel like as we talked
about a while ago
um as we've been going on and on um that
we're meant to cultivate this connection
with ourself and our and our in our
inner being and our higher self and the
connection to everything because that's
how it is um since we're just energy
which is how quantum entanglement works
when something is happening when once
particles have been entangled they will
then forever have a resonance with each
other and
einstein called it spooky things
happening at a distance and didn't like
it because it wasn't quantifiable but
it's a reality and i felt like there was
there was a the temples were were meant
for
cultivating um
magic
and we think about magic as being like
oh magic is funny and not real right
yeah magic's just [ __ ] we can't explain
yeah unknown science miracles and magic
or just things you cannot explain yet
yep i'm with you the workings of the
universe in a way that is as mysterious
as whether they call it black matter so
because like a vast it's something like
94 or 95 maybe it's 96 percent of all
matter in the universe is considered to
be dark where we can't even
comprehend it and i'm like
i'm like what i'm like people read on
this like they read up on dark matter
and how they're discovering that a vast
majority of all existence itself is
unseen by the eye even light there are
different um
i forgot how many different frequencies
have been identified of light like like
um
actually like measured in hertz but it
is unbelievably more than the human eye
can even comprehend
and all these things is essentially
science explaining that there are things
that exist that are not yet capable of
being
identified through technology or even
the human senses obviously and i'm like
the implications of that in itself are
i think it's wild i think it's it's
proof that there's more going on beyond
the veil of the human eyes like i was
saying earlier yeah yeah i think that
but i think i i think those temples were
used to cultivate this um these these
this magic that we used to use
just like we'd use things that we
wouldn't call magic you know magic was
magic was real magic is real
and um you know it's why the power of
belief work it's it's why um
thoughts become things
law of attraction all that stuff like
you can't really quantify it you can't
yeah this isn't like this isn't
scientifically proven it's just
trends
and um and and something powerful beyond
what we've been able to prove
scientifically i am so curious
to ask you because i look at you i'm
like this person is a powerful manifesto
i look at your life and different things
i'm like none of it's an accident like
you it to me i'm like it seems like this
person
had chosen like you're saying early in
the conversation that you had saw
yourself getting to that level like
within racing i forgot exactly how you
worded it but like had you visualized
that you were going to become like on
the world stage like years and years
before it happened yeah when i was like
10 years old i wanted to be i wanted to
win the indy 500 when i was 10.
holy [ __ ] and then i moved to england
when i was 16. i lost my i didn't have a
job when i was 19. i lived there for
three years and raced came back didn't
have a ride but for some reason i still
believed i was gonna make it i just did
the power belief is everything like have
you um when you say magic exists and i
personally i believe in i have my own
examples why it's been proven to me
magic is like a placebo
and yeah it's exchange of energy energy
is you're tracking things i don't know
if i want to call it magnetism or
gravity or what but i'm like we
literally whether it's through words
thoughts intention and feeling and
belief
because this is one of the things i was
um on a podcast not long ago and i was
trying to make the point but i kind of
lost my train of thought and i was
trying to say like i was using the
example that were made up of stardust in
that so people can google this like
94 of all elements in the human body are
emitting constantly from the sun as well
as prior supernovas so i'm like whoa
whoa hold on a second so like
countless tons of stardust are being
reigned
on earth every year and and 94 of all
elements in the human body originates
from the sun in those supernovas and i'm
like
so we are literally stardust and the
fact we're talking about it and the fact
that i believe i can manipulate my
reality through the power of belief
and intention and words because this is
something i've been playing with now for
the last handful of years
and and and now i i know beyond any
doubt i'm like this it works but a lot
of people if they haven't had it's hard
for people to believe because i was
raised catholic and i smelt the [ __ ]
early on but when i was told belief from
a christian standpoint i was to me i
interpreted as like oh oh
believe or else you're in trouble you're
going to hell don't forget to put money
in the collection plate on your way out
or else you know manifesting uh is about
thinking of an idea
um visualizing actually as an as an
example of manifestation ability um
uh it was how i ended up in egypt i was
at i was doing uh joe dispenza one day
event that's i love that guy by the way
yeah and um at the end of it he was
teaching us this manifestation technique
where you
um
think of what it is that you want and
want to want to attract and it could be
anything it could be a car shopping a
trip like whatever anything and write
down the letter to represent it and then
on one side of the letter
what are you know a handful of reasons
why and then on the other side a handful
of elevated emotions having achieved it
and and and have it
and so in the in the at the end of the
meditation we went into the
manifestation of it and you visualized
yourself truly there so i visualized
myself in and i wanted to manifest egypt
so i visualized myself there how it felt
um the feelings that i would have around
it the emotions the just like the of it
like all the things like i really put
myself there and then two hours after
went to dinner some girl tapped me on
the shoulder and she was like i heard
that you're interested in egypt and i
was like holy [ __ ] what
and um i said did you know what i wrote
down i was like did i tell everyone or
something she goes no she said you just
you were talking about egypt with
somebody earlier she goes there's a trip
in february if you want to go
that's the trip i ended up going on
isn't that crazy
yeah that is crazy i mean there's a lot
of other things that are really
interesting too like as an example the
the leader of it that that put the group
together her name is isis um not given
name i'm pretty sure
isis was an insanely wonderful egyptian
goddess
um and so when i was
developing my wife like moved into my
house here and doing my wi-fi one of the
parts of my uh wi-fi is has isis in it
and yeah and then there was there was a
bunch of other things like i had a ring
that uh
an isis ring that i had bought years
before
years before uh isis ran i couldn't even
remember who it was i was like god i
gotta look this up what was the
significance of this again and so like i
bought the ring um
isis was my wi-fi it was a little bit
more but i'm not trying to tell everyone
my wifi name and um and then um
and then isis was leading this event i
had manifested the egypt trip like all
in two hours of like thinking about
wanting it for real though you know like
it's one thing to say i want to go there
and it's another thing to actually apply
a technique to it so anyway the point is
is that intention
and embodying the feeling and anchoring
anchoring the reality with emotion
with visceral emotion is insanely
powerful
so
i 100 agree
and this is something i didn't all right
so i i was living alone in boise i all
right so to people who don't know much
about me like i i went through this path
of depression like so
basically that rewind a few years i got
divorced i'm real depressed i'm living
alone in boise with the dogs and i'm
just creating my youtube and i'm
spending a vast majority of my time
alone
and
with that i re there's a lot of benefits
when you spend a lot of time alone you
start to kind of learn more about
yourself you kind of cut them out of
your shell more you realize how much
being around other people affect you and
like sharing different things when
you're utterly alone for long periods of
time like i am working alone i hardly
knew anyone out there i didn't have any
family and it's like so i started like
playing around with the universe and i
was able to i guess be more open-minded
especially since i was at certain
moments of the just despair just
depressed just like you know wanting
help and um just to be happy i guess and
so i started playing around with stuff
and over time i started to hear
different things different people were
saying and i was like dabbling in the
law of attraction
and i figured some things out along the
way
and
i guess long story short like everything
you just said it's all about
visualizing and believing the end
results because people
that want something
that's what you're putting out is want
and you're only ever going to get back
as once you're going to spend the rest
of your life wanting something you're
never going to have it because that's
exactly what you're telling the universe
to give you so
i remember hearing um a few different
people say something and i'll mention
her name even though um
i may well i don't want to say look i'll
do all right so oprah she's been
unbelievably successful i honestly agree
with everything
but she advocated for the clinton so
like that's a red flag to me but anyway
i'll shut up um but she is a powerful
manifesto and she has said it i found
this little known interview by her it
has like no views at all on youtube and
she tells this person who i've never
heard of just a small little interview
who knows what she was up to and she's
the girl that said something about hey
you're in you know you manifest french
like yeah you wanna know how i do it
she's like yeah and she says
and i'm paraphrasing she said something
to the effect of what you already said
which is that i
put myself i know how to put myself on
the frequency and believing i already
have it and adding the feeling to it and
i get it every time
so let's so fast forward so hold on i
was already at that when she said that i
already knew that was true i was like
what the [ __ ] i already figured
something this out so hold on
so i was like i said i was raised
catholic but i picked up on the bs early
on i refused to be confirmed my dad was
all mad at me about it i'm like no no no
i'm like i now there's anyone that was
raised catholic would know that every
sunday they read this the same passage
off every single sunday that year to
date so essentially every year or
forever in the catholic church you only
hear so many bible verses
and it's a limited amount for a book
that's really really freaking big so i
spent years blown off the bible didn't
take it serious at all i'm like okay
whatever it's a bunch of stories but i
find it quite interesting
that so many people had had put things
together for thousands of years and i'm
like there's got to be some truth to it
so all right let me just fast forward to
what i'm getting at is that to me
there the bible has been massively
misinterpreted and there's a man named
neville goddard have you ever heard of
him
i know him yep
he looks at it he talks about it yes he
talks about it talks about going to
sleep every time you go to bed you
should visualize what you want to make
it happen
yes and he's so to people listening he
is he says and this makes total sense to
me now he says the bible has been
completely misinterpreted and it should
be read as in first person as if you
wrote it so he says
and i believe him because this is i've
tested this and i was already testing it
beforehand so it was validation is what
i'm trying to tell people it wasn't like
i heard someone say this i tried it on
the work it was like no it valid i'm
like oh my god this is what's making
sense to me so hold on i have in front
of me i brought up on my computer but
there are three bible verses
and i had never heard these in my entire
life and i find it very concerning so
this is going to be mark 9 23 matthew 21
22 and mark 11 24. let me just say
because i always used to scoff off bible
verses i'm like
matthew mark luke and john those names
didn't even exist when the bible was
written like it's [ __ ] like they put
a bunch of i'll just say a bunch of
white man names in there like i'm like
regular regular old names anyone hearing
this i always use i know what it's like
to scoff off the bible but it doesn't
mean that there isn't any uh information
in there that's not accurate right so
so here's let me just read them all off
because it confirms what you said and i
and and and before people think that i'm
trying to like poison their minds with
some religious divide you know whatever
just test things out for yourself and
think people so here's what they are
sorry
all things are possible to him who
believes
and all things whatsoever you ask in
prayer believing
ye shall receive therefore i tell you
whatever you ask in prayer
believe that you have received it
and it will be yours so what it's
telling you is to live
in the moment so anything that i've
manifested and i'll share some stories
in a minute if you want
it was literally
so when it says prayer people it means
the power of your imagination
don't prayer isn't like oh give me this
oh i want a car give it to me please no
no it's it's it's visualizing it's using
your imagination which is somehow made
all right again we're made of stardust
and you can you can you can imagine
something like that's all inventions
came from imagination exactly everything
came from imagination so what it's
saying it's all misinterpreted and i
believe this to be true because i've
tested it a million times and i've had
the most bizarre synchronicities and
things come to fruition so i know it's
real um but i don't i say it to somebody
don't believe jimmy don't believe danica
just test it and what am i telling you
just believe something this is a if
nothing else this is a positive mindset
like if people don't want to believe the
google part of it which i let me just
say i do believe i do we believe we have
powers that involve gravity or magnetism
or something
we're talking magic here but what i'm
saying is that this is like future
science in that this is the reality of
how things work and it's just beyond our
understanding and it might sound crazy
to some but when i'm i'm not trying to
make you believe anything here what i'm
trying to say is that if nothing else
remove the woo if nothing else
the benefits of putting an intention out
there and having that confidence and
belief in yourself that you can do it
and pursue it
um and just visualize what that end
result will look like and add the
feeling behind it
it will be yours and there's another i
don't have it in front of me but there's
another passage that says that to those
that have all and i'm paraphrasing those
that have all they're going to get more
and those who have nothing all will be
taken away and the way neville god
describes it is that it's saying that
because of those that figured this out
it becomes easier and easier to manifest
because you can believe because you know
what it's like to have miracles happen
and you know it can happen but with
where other people have a more
non-believing nihilistic viewpoint they
ain't gonna get [ __ ] because that
self-doubt self-doubt is so destructive
you'll never get anything if you doubt
so i don't continue to get what you're
going to continue to get more of what
you don't think you should get
yeah yeah because that's what you're
putting out the universe is going to
give you whatever you want if you want a
miserable [ __ ] on earth existence you
can totally have it and also
if you want something it's implying you
don't have it and so the universe kind
of gets confused and so the energy is
like a resistant energy because you're
like oh i just want it so bad
ah
and really the truth of that frequency
is that you don't have it and so that
kind of continues as well and that's all
you'll ever get is that not to have
and that's why i have to let go you have
to
know what you want
go through a manifestation technique
believe that you can have it and then
let it go
because i don't know how it's going to
come it might show up tomorrow or in 10
years
but
but trust that it's at the right time
with the right situation
and that you you don't always know
exactly how it should go down our
timelines are you know we have our own
timeline of how things should go but
when we release timelines it actually
accelerates them
and so
i totally i think that's such a
fascinating thing to to share with
people um
i think because we've gone so long and i
believe that we could do like a whole
series here we didn't even talk about
the moon we didn't talk about
ai we didn't talk about jfk there's like
a million things we didn't talk about we
just don't have enough time um
so i think maybe uh just to wrap it up
because we've talked about a lot of
really fun things and you have for
anyone who wants to watch more your
videos are just so dense with
information i feel like i've lost them
five times to get it um but they're
really informational um but what is like
the one thing that you feel like if i
could get out of this life
having a much more
confident understanding of or maybe even
let's go further with it let's say if
you could know one truth that you're
seeking that you're trying to figure out
what would that one thing be that you
would want to know the truth of
well it goes oh my god it goes along the
lines of what we just talked about i'm
very so when we talk about all these
things involving manifestation i guess
it involves what is all this and is this
are we part of a one consciousness what
is i am what is god what is
the what is existence and i guess if if
i've already confirmed that there's
that we have powers that that aren't
supposed to exist based on anything
we're taught in organized religion or
school or whatever like we're just about
just power of belief let's say uh and
what can come in your life because of it
um
i mean i'd love to tell you like i'd
like to know what what
the great pyramid was because that's up
there i want to know that like if i
could travel back in time it's gonna be
like
i need i need to see what was going on
in egypt 4 500 years because it answers
so many other questions for me but
um i do believe that because i'm very
like we're talking real early on i'm
concerned about the direction of
humanity so i think if there's nothing
else it'd be the understanding to know
that people that you can and and do
create your own reality happiness is a
choice success um or not success let's
say excellence excellence is not a skill
set it is an attitude and anything you
want in life you can get so for me i
guess it's more finding a way to
communicate this to others
um
so i don't know uh that's a really great
truth so it's the pyramid it sounds like
it's the pyramid that's like the one
thing that you'd like to know right
because you can help people that's what
you're doing right now is sharing your
experiences to inspire people to
you know use this information to better
their life and be happier and more
successful and and live and live in more
excellence
so it's the pyramid that's your that's
your final answer
yeah all right because let me just say
if like
if you think that tesla was still around
like that man was so far ahead of his
time and how he got all of his
inventions he was convinced the things
we just said he was convinced that ideas
were coming to him from the the fabric
and wheel work of the universe itself
he didn't invent things by touching this
and building like okay i'm gonna adapt
he would sit there he said a vast
majority of his time was sitting doing
nothing and he said ideas would pop and
said randomly and he believed that they
were being sent to him and i'm like i
know what he's means because it's
happened to me and i know it sounds so
silly to some people because i'm just
like this i'm making youtubes in my
spare bedroom with my dog staring at me
and like but like to me i do take pride
i'm making like a thumbnail and a title
because i'm like if i if i want to tell
people that the rich shot structure
might be atlantis how the hell do i make
that damn video and i'm like sometimes i
get this flash for a title or thumbnail
that will help more people to see it and
i know that sounds silly to some but it
means something to me and i'm like but
sometimes i wonder i'm like i i will go
from struggling with no idea and then
i've been in um examples of like uh
sensory deprivation tanks like float
tanks i don't know if you've ever done
that but i've got wild ideas in there
that panned out oh you haven't tried
that
no but i've i bet it feels like laying
insects things chamber
sarcophagus
it's a must try to anybody it's there's
no better man there's no other way
let me reword this the most profound way
to meditate at least for someone like me
that struggles to be able to sit still
go put your ass in for an hour or an
hour and a half into a saltwater sensory
deprivation float tank where they you
eliminate all senses virtually
because like i i was i was it blew me
away and i did it i had a membership
back and i lived in boise so i haven't
done this in a year but i was going
every week and it it it benefited my
life profoundly
and even my success because i got ideas
i'm living i'm literally sitting in a
dark closed thing with nothing else to
do and it came ideas that gave that that
gave me exactly what i needed at that
time and i'm like so i know it works i'm
like what the hell did this idea come
when i'm just sitting still and some
people oh you're just focusing you're
just concentrating like whatever i don't
know all i know is that i didn't have
the idea before and now i do so as
nikola tesla said
to wrap it up
if you want to know the secrets of the
universe you need to think in terms of
frequency energy and vibration
and i might have got the three things in
the wrong order but that's basically
that you nailed it
and i think that what we've talked about
is a whole lot of that whether it was
how the pyramids were made what the
temples were for what's possible with
human existence with manifesting or with
magic it's all about frequency and
energy and vibration and that's all we
are anyway so it's really about how do
we use how do we manipulate how do we
use how do we how do we move with the
universe and i think we're all just
trying to figure it out and i know that
you're
the part that you play and educating
people on your research and um all of
these ancient mysteries
um i hope you figure out what the
pyramid uh truth is maybe maybe it just
comes to you in a vision or a dream but
um but i hope you figure it out and um
please pass it along
and in the meantime keep keep making
your videos because they're educating a
lot of us and they're just fascinating
so it's been really fun to talk to you
thank you danica that means a lot and
same to you i'm very excited to see
where this next venture takes you in
life i think that you know the racing
and all that was spectacular but i'm
super curious because you're so young
you're so vibrant you're like this
really bright soul you're smart you're
intuitive and you have this passion to
explore the unknown and my words you're
you're going on to something else i
don't know what it is you might not know
what it is but like something's coming
and i'm excited to see where it takes
you too so and if you ever want to do it
again let's do it because i got a bunch
of notes i made up on the moon in
antarctica oh good there's there's
things going on in the moon so we'll
save that for another time and
underneath the ice cap underneath the
ice in antarctica okay we'll touch on
that next time okay all right thank you
again everyone hey go subscribe to
danica patrick's podcast and
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the subscribe button